hello everybody aloha hello so i was like oh my god oh my god that's the third loop i gotta start now i was like oh it's the third loop oh no wait i was like chowing down my lunch my by the way it's okay it sounds very sad my microwave my microwaved reheated steak i got my leftover steak And I got reheated in a microwave.
I was like, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum.
Yeah, no, yeah, no, I know.
It sounds very sad.
Steak is steak.
So I was like, I'm trying to finish as fast as I could before like in the three loops.
Okay.
Well, it's not really story time, but like, dad bit me because um he got a little too excited hi robert i'm robert again thank you for the super chat thank you thank you so um um i was trying to get the ball and then he like he like the ball was still in his mouth and he's like and then he first time he's ever broke skin um it's okay we got him rabies shots so it's okay uh my parents made sure that he had his rabies shot so don't worry guys i can still drink water um but like you know and then i consistently kept him uh kept him on his shots um but yes no he's tasted blood it's over uh yeah he started his rebellious phase um as a middle-aged dog um but yes no um so he like bit me on the inside like the you know the where the joy where the finger connects to the palm um he bit me there because i was trying to grab the ball and then um and then like he uh he was like no and you know he was like like like like like like that so like the obviously he thought he was still biting on his ball
but he would he bit my finger charlie dad bit my finger charlie bit my finger oh my god i can't believe that was a fucking meme but where are we as a society uh um now i know they even super chat thank you today's my birthday as a barely functioning adult i accomplished a last year getting a job and thinking about college etc and hope i can accomplish more this year thank you for the super chat thank you thank you i hope you have a wonderful birthday and accomplish much more happy birthday to you happy birthday to you happy birthday dear nano happy birthday to you yay happy birthday also um i know like i know i'm like you guys are like please stop talking about my revivals but my revivals update um i talked to the organizers um and uh they might i don't know if they will but like i might have to off-roll so like i don't know if they are gonna do it but uh um because like we were i was like giving suggestions on how we can make it more fun and let's like try hard i was like oh you could
put all the eternity plus players on off-roll i'm not playing take i swear i would fucking play would i don't care um if we have four dps i'm playing dps um so so um um and i said like oh i don't think it'd be we don't know what's gonna happen like because um i i said like um oh like an eternity player has so much more game sense map knowledge and skill wise over a celestial player I don't know you guys understand the gap between Celestial and Eternity.
It's actually like, no, like whenever a Celestial player gets accidentally gets into an Eternity lobby, like they get yelled at.
Like you could tell that they do not belong in that lobby because like the knowledge between a Celestial player and Eternity player is such a huge gap that like every, I know because I play Ranks.
So every time a Celestial player sneaks into an eternity lobby, they always get yelled at, and they try to pick DPS.
They're like, no, get on support.
You do not touch DPS.
Or like, get off of Tick.
No.
So, because they're asking me, like, do you think Celestial players should also be on their off roles?
And I was like, I said personally, I don't know.
um because uh um because like i don't know i don't know these players but i do know that a celestial three player versus a celestial one player is also a huge gap between knowledge because you know celestial one is closer to eternity versus celestial three who's closer to grandmaster um especially if that's their peak if they piece celestial three then like i know you've never like hit that elo where you could play with the eternity players or like you know sometimes you do but you know you don't play often with eternity players so um so like you know i'm trying to help them figure out you know as someone that organized tournaments before i'm trying to help them especially like for hero shooters because i think hero shooters is the hardest thing to um is the hardest thing to figure out in terms of like how do you balance a hero shooter when all roles are different because it's like 70 support players in this tournament um so so how do you balance when 70% of the people you have in this
tournament are essentially support players and we have two tier tank players.
There's only two tank players.
Like they can other support players can off-roll as tank players, but like it's still an off-roll.
So it's like more so of like, um, how, how do you, how do you balance a tournament when it's 70% support players, 1% tank players, and the rest it's DPS.
So it's very, like there are, no, they have like, you know, like second role, like, you know, like, what is your main role and what is your second role?
Obviously, your second role will never be as good as your first role because when you're playing your second role, you're essentially flexing, you know?
So they're asking me about that.
And I said, I told them personally, I don't know I think for sure um to make it more fun um each turn players should off roll and I said I don't you know how it's like I hope I don't off roll but if I have to to make this tournament more fun for everyone I will even though like I would love to play support um but I you know I understand that like you know I will take it for the team and I'll off roll just so everyone can a more fun time because there's no reason why they want me to offer because i told them yesterday i did my placement matches i did all 10 of my placements matches and um because i was like i got it you know i have the practice for the tournament um because everyone was like oh it's for fun the prize money is 7.5k for first place um and um um anyway so i obviously i didn't try out the new season yet and I was like oh okay I should really see what the new meta is and like see how to play in this new Elo and also try out Gambit because in my head I was like um in my head
I was like the only way I can carry my team as a support play is I have to play Gambit because Gambit a lot of people are like Gambit is the cure code no Gambit is the honor of of Marvel rivals um because you don't use your cleanse the only thing you do on gambit this is what i've learned because i actually asked my pro friends um how to play gambit like you know and then like all them like you have to play like sipe who is currently who is like rank one support in the world and sipe got rank one on gambit and basically everyone was like um you barely use your cleanse because what you do is you have to use your anti-heal every like all the time it's all about anti-heal so he is basically the honor of marvel rivals because you're just and like and then my friends they're like um no dps can 1v1 a gambit anymore because his util is so good anti-heal means when you use it when he use it and it's like a it's like a hit scan anti-heal too it's not even projectile the anti-heal is so broken
it does damage and it does anti and you have to I could technically spam two and then the supports are dead so um so he's so fucking strong and his dash and his dash is so good too so I um so I did all my placement matches and um yeah he can heal while using his mobility too so Gabbit is very fucking strong right now and it's like my friends were like who are pros are like no TPS player can confidently 1v1 um gambit and gambit anymore because he's that like that good of a support and then he was like uh he's like basically he can kill all the other supports um even if like if he has like a if he he could pick off any support player on the enemy team with his anti-heal and his like left click And so,
so I was like, that can't be true.
There's no way that, uh, uh, I was like, there's no way he's that good.
Like, there's, like, oh my gosh, like, you know, I was like in denial.
So then I was like, I'm gonna go, you know, I'm gonna go do my placement matches and then see how, how it's gonna be like.
like i think this is my second placement match and i need you guys to know this was in a lobby of gm1s and celestial players and top 500 is celestial 2 right now
look at this look at this stat line very carefully
and also look at my final it's i was it was basically a one v one i literally you win if i went with winning one v ones against spider-man and iron fist and and i've only I've only had one loss on Gambit.
And whenever I got to play Gambit, I've only had one loss on Gambit when I had to.
And I played six games on him.
And so, yeah, so he's like, he's very strong.
But Gambit is the only character I believe.
And Mantis.
It's Gambit and Mantis that you can use.
to no they had a gambit but he swapped off because he was shit like the enemy team had a gambit but they swapped off because obviously he wasn't doing as good as the other gambit so it's not like so if i could do that in a high elo lobby imagine what i could do in like the vtuber tournament as gambit like he is the only character i believe that can that can confidently i can say can actually 1v4 a team if i just take off angles and we play triple support so i was telling them i was just like oh um i feel like you know if i was on gap like maybe they'll just ban gambit but i was just like if i was gonna get gambit this is not gonna be fun also luna is hard not meta luna is trash right And then I am confident because me on Gambit,
I can bully the lower ELO supports easily or the lower ELO DPS players because I was already bullying the DPS players that were in my ELO.
That's the thing.
I was already bullying the support and DPS players in my ELO.
so yeah like if i had to go against people who are lower elo than me i think i couldn't like it would not be fun for them so so um so they were like yeah we might we will need you to off off roll and i was like i'm fine with that like i was even saying like i don't think it's fair you put me on gambit
I was just like, um, I was just like, oh, I, I also, I, like, I even, I was like, I don't think it's fair if you put me in Gambit, like, because, like, Gambit is, like, a DPS now, and if I run triple support, my two supports can just pocket the rest of the team,
and I can just take off angle and play, like, a triple, like, a second DPS or a third DPS.
Like, um, like, I could literally just play as a second DPS, and, like, his util is so fucking broken.
healing dps um so he is a self-healing dps which is already pretty scary with anti-heal
so so i was like i just feel i feel like i like if at that point everyone in eternity plus maybe we need to off roll i know i'm like you know maybe like i get shit on as gambit um leon if i can play gambit i just don't i don't i'm just like thinking like i don't think it's playing Gambit and all I do is just like like use all my util to kill their supports because like that's what I was literally doing like here in this game so I had literally I only lost one game on Gambit there all the times I got to play him and um and so like there is potentially a chance that um I'm gonna have to off-roll um just to make it fair for everyone
um um what if the top five and gps offer us to gambit then i'm gonna ban gambit i have first ban we all if we all have first ban i'll just ban gambit i'm not fucking giving them gambit like but if everyone knows that i'm gonna play gambit then gambit's just gonna be permaband for me as well and then like and then like what the fuck do i do like i can't hard carry as anything else but mantis like and even then my mantis is not that good compared to like because i still like i hate aiming with mantis i don't know how to fully aim with mantis because um because like he's uh he's like hard to penny is so strong but not really um there's only penny players that play penny she's still not that she's still not the strongest tanks in rivals um so that's like off topic but I had to talk also they were like if we off-role will you be captain again and I didn't respond back you want to give me the captain title because I guess it looks better if like you know team dokeybird because they want like
because like the thing is the captains um they're not all the high-ranked players it's the play it's like basically the most well-known vtubers are captains so so like you know like whoever is like more like you know the most well-known vtubers they give the captain spot to so they they want us to like be the face of the team like you know be the face so like you know oh look it's this team this team this team and yeah it's for the publicity so they're like they're like would you be captain get we implement the off-roll thing and i'm just like my gosh i really don't want to be captain i i'm okay with being captain if I get to pick my team but like I just feel weird about being captain um um no it's pre-assigned the entire all the teams are pre-assigned as well and apparently I don't know if this is true I don't know I got a little confused but it was supposed to be like uh oh um it's supposed to be an all na tournament and then apparently uh but it wasn't that clear so some eu player
players sneaked in so then they were like oh sorry we have to find na players to replace you guys because you're not supposed to be in this tournament na only um so like they can't announce anything yet because they have to um they have to find like na replacements i don't know didn't realize it was i think i think it was in the rule oh yeah i think it was it was in the rules that it was supposed in the forum it was supposed to be na but like um they didn't fully check the i guess like they didn't fully check it um but so that's why like nothing is real it's region locked nothing is fully yeah it wasn't said it was said in the forum that it was na only but some eu players applied for it so they have to like be like sorry guys it sucks it sucks but But,
you know, if it's, I think it has to do with, like, prizes as well, because I know, like, some prizes, like, you know, like, transferring prize money and everything, it has to, like, regarding, like, guidelines on how to transfer prize money, especially for taxes and everything,
it makes sense to keep it within NA, because it gets more complicated, if you're outside of NA, and you have to, like, you have to fill in, like, special tax forms and stuff to receive prizes.
money and everything hmm so like so like because of that that's why i'm not surprised it's NA locked because you don't want to deal with the headaches of like the headache of trying to figure out um tax money like how to you know fill out the tax forms for the prize money in itself so yeah so i don't know when teams would be announced i don't know if the special rules are going to be implemented i did say maybe test out the off-roll rule just in case like do like like a practice match to see if teams are not balanced or not because I don't know.
Like it's so I was looking at the forum and even I was like, how do you balance this?
Like I'm so glad I don't have to handle the balancing for this because looking at that forum, I was just like, oh my God, how do you balance this?
Because like you guys might be thinking like, oh, why don't you just find players for all roles.
The thing is, um, to run a tournament, also have to find people that have the viewership as well to prop up the numbers because you know all rivals all rivals want is to make sure that um their game is advertised to as many people as possible so um so because of that like they want to make it balanced to the point where like you know the bigger streamers there's also enough balance of the bigger streamers but you know the bigger streamers play support you know like all the streamers majority of the streamers that are that have the numbers and the um and the skill level in the different skill level are support players so so you know that's what can you do so that's what a tournament has a lot of support players and it's i i do you know i don't even know how the fuck they balance this it's so hard i was literally looking at you asking my opinion being like being like what do you do you think do you think we should give celestia off roll and i was like i don't know i know you turn any
plus shit off roll i know i damn know for sure you turn any plus shit off roll because i was
um so yeah anyway ow i clapped and then hit the hit the bite wound um anyway so that is the marvel rivals update for today um oh yeah one more thing um i bump i when i was playing off stream i bumped you know i was bumping to other like streamers and pro players and one streamer slash pro was like
YokeyBrain, why aren't you streaming?
Like, they typed in the chat, in the match chat while we were in game.
And then I replied back, he was on the enemy team.
I replied back, I don't know.
Why wasn't I nominated?
I know, that's so fucking petty.
But I was like, bro, it's off stream.
It's off stream at 2 in the morning.
I can see where the fuck I want.
I'm so salty
I know that's it's so fanny I know that's like bro I'm fucking gonna play hot like bro I have nothing no there's no whatsoever I I gain nothing anymore and then they're just like and then they were like oh dot dot dot
I'm valid as fuck
But like I have nothing to, yeah There's nothing to lose But anyway, I just didn't want to style it I was trying to practice for I was just wanting to do my place in matches Um Uh And oh yeah And I placed Celestial 3 Um for those who are wondering is Celestial 2 and I play Celestial 3.
Thanks, Gambit.
Shout out to you, Gambit.
And for those who are wondering, like, wait, if Gambit's so strong, why isn't he bad?
Because other characters are also very strong and scary.
Daredevil is so strong and the must bands, what I've learned is Daredevil, SILOC, Emma, Hella.
These are, like, the four top bands at the moment.
So, like um so these are the four that everyone sort of always bans which i've noticed is daredevil sidlock emma hella because they're so scary there there's too many strong heroes because gambit um he um the thing is to play gambit well is that you have to have the other support also doing a lot of healing so the gambit has to rely on the other support to be able to do whatever the fuck he wants to do and it's it's literally a gambit yeah it's a gamble to play gambit because there's also a lot of shitty gambit players
gambit um gambit there's a lot of very shitty gambit players and they all a lot of people think you have to be a heal like think that like um oh it's do your dps on gambit or you be a heal bot no you have to balance between the two you have to balance between the two but you use your Your card ability to do anti-heal.
That's literally it.
You barely use it for anything else.
Like, you don't really use it for healing.
You don't use it for cleanse.
You just use it for mostly anti-heal.
Cleanse is mostly for Bucky alt or Groot alt.
That's it.
But everything else, it's like, you know, you use it for anti.
Anyway, let's play Dispatch.
I don't know.
Okay, I forgot to ask.
All right.
Okay, so we have Soundgap.
Sorry, Soundgap.
I know you waited 30 minutes.
I forgot to save my Soundgap.
for dispatch so he's here to rebalance balance it for me um because I forgot to save it it's okay it's the last stream for it today anyway um thank you guys afternoon stream so um I don't have to worry too much uh about streaming way too late all right let's see here here I think it was like i'll see if sound guy figures this out okay thank you super chat thank you thank you doki is too powerful she needs to put on shackles of dps in order to be on everyone else's power level thank you super chat thank you thank you um also people got really mad that i was robber look look i gotta live with my mistakes we can't all always have good endings guys unlucky year for me this year like and i'm gonna reflect that in my dispatch playthrough um we all have to live with our consequences like not every ending is a good ending why do you think we have criminals do you think they're happy to be in prison like look look i am running the i don't care if i'm heading towards a bad ending sometimes life
is like that sometimes you just live the life where you have bad things happen to you and i'm robert
f2p thank you for the super chat thank you thank you it's i've been really enjoying you play this game so i'm happy to watch you finish it on my birthday as well thank you for the super chat thank you thank you happy birthday to you happy birthday to you happy birthday dear f2p happy birthday to you Happy birthday!
Alright, let's go.
It's Robert time.
It's time to be Robert for another day.
If I wanted to bat him to stop playing the game and live my life, the thing is, I don't know what my choices are going to make me, so I got to live with my consequences.
If I make a bad choice, fuck me.
There's no going back.
I don't purposely...
playing knowing where my choices end up to i play pick choices that i think is pretty funny because like i'm not gonna make these choices these bad choices in real life
bro you missed the 3 a.m tacos you're sick as hell This was 3 a.m.
Taco.
And despite all of that.
That's nice.
I guess that was.
Sounds like my local Taco Bell.
Engaging protocols.
Game audio can be raised.
Sound guy.
What do you think?
It's fine.
I'll just, I'll raise it just in case.
All right.
I raised it a little bit.
Now.
All reading super stable.
Here we go.
Oh?
I got a flex.
Wait, no superhero pose.
All right.
Ready for lunch.
Roger that.
Gotta be a superhero, even though I'm retired.
I'm going to eat my cold microwave steak now.
Oh, my girlfriend here is to support me.
Did I do it?
That's the superhero pose.
pose not the landing one bro the landing one would have been cooler
bro you know like the spider-man one or like the superman pose i thought the same too but i think the purple is a nice touch what smoke what oh that's not supposed to happen yeah i was like where did the purple smoke come from bro
my future boyfriend.
Don't worry, I know I have two more episodes, so I can't be dying.
I'm not...
I know he's gonna live, because there's still episode 7 and 8.
Oh, shit!
Don't worry, I live this, right?
I'm just gonna be in the hospital.
The last two episodes are just a blank screen.
I'm like, in the last two episodes is me in purgatory.
Yeah, see, I knew I was alive.
Oh, look, there's my badass dog.
I love you.
Wait, he got more injured than me?
How long was I out?
Yeah.
About 14, 15 hours, I think.
Bro, he broke his arm and has a concussion and I just have like...
Yeah.
It's over, brother.
I cannot recreate the Astral Pulse.
What?
Too much power.
Too small size.
We'll just make it bigger.
No pulse mean I can't make the man Mecca.
I'm not good enough, bro.
No!
No, don't say that!
I must bring down the whole team.
I believe in you.
you let's get everybody blowed up hey listen bro i believe as long as i believe in you you can do anything it's not a literally game brother this real life no oh i should have been like just a minor setback you did your best i can't ask for anything else thank you
Yeah, fisted.
I heard that big bastard crying in the bathroom.
Makes it hard to shit when someone's doing that next to you, you know?
Pretty distracting.
No.
Everyone else okay?
And Vizzy girl?
Fine.
One thing she's good at is disappearing when people get hurt.
What's your deal with her?
You give everyone shit, but it always seems extra with Vizzy.
She's a liability.
And one of us needs to be objective.
when it's clear something's going on between the two of you.
Don't think I don't see it.
Do you think she likes me?
Wait, do you think she likes me, bro?
She's like, she's like, she's bad, bro.
And like, bro, you think she likes me?
Can you ask her in PE?
Maybe put a note in her locker for me?
Ha, ha, motherfucker.
But this little bitch you're doing?
Do you think I have a shot?
Because you wouldn't be joking like this if you didn't have a thing for.
Look.
Just be careful, kid.
Some people did black holes.
You reach out to help them, and they just suck you in and do whatever the fuck black holes do.
I don't know.
They fuck you up.
Bro, did she fuck me up, bro?
Your new look screams I know some science shit, so I was with you.
Oh, we can bring it a little more.
Okay, let me double check the audio real quick.
Sound.
Yeah, we're already up the sound a lot.
So we'll just up a little more here.
up with it a little more i'm gonna take the day off no really bro i'm fine she's gonna me up bro just throw say no more in the infirmary think about that i'll move it over
it's like she he's trying to warn me about her and i'm like yo you think she likes me he's like bro there's so many red flags and i'm like she actually likes me enhanced proceed with What are you doing up?
Turns out I'm completely fine.
Just sort of time traveled several hours into the future where I feel pretty rested.
Cool, yeah.
That happens to me every night.
Wish I could say the same.
How's your ship going?
Oh wait, she takes my ship?
Challenging.
Made worse by all the enhanced villains we're dealing with lately.
Enhanced villains?
Oh!
The Xbox ring.
Oh, yeah, I know she had to handle his, her, her ex, too.
Give us some time.
Roy's a little down, but I'm sure we can come up with alternate power sources.
Hey, really looking forward to tonight.
Perfect timing.
Yeah, same.
Also, like, Invisible Girl is so smart to fuck the dispatcher, because that means she'll get more jobs and get sent on the easier job.
Congrats on that.
Oh, they got me a gift.
She's so smart.
Wait, I have to just...
Okay.
I need someone to wait patiently in the long line for the game drop.
Blend in with the line to not look like...
I think depression.
Oh, wait.
No, that should be...
As one of the most well-known game reviewers here, Moist Zoner would be the perfect one to send in.
I need to...
pop on down to this store can someone watch there's no hr in this department i'd refuse to believe there is an hr entertain hops the cat while the owner's way keep a watchful eye on him i think prism can do it wait actually you know what let's have you and prism there we go all right we need two it's a cat guys you don't understand a cat needs three people to entertain yeah oh my God,
make a new friend.
Okay, here you go.
Wait, it's a fucking tiger?
It's like a goddamn NPC.
This is you talking, Robert.
Taco shit.
Oh, I knew it.
Yeah, because Golem's really good with animals.
Yeah, we did it.
Yeah, let's go with that.
I had taco shits.
This does many special jobs, but they're not.
Didn't you say you could handle spicy food?
Yes, which is why this doesn't make sense as an excuse.
but oh shit okay i swear to god if i get nah i'm still gonna drink it i don't care if it tears a hole in my stomach all right we should not go for combat guys let me do one mobility surely that helps out right oh cyberbullying he's hacking to my notes app he's fucking with all my stand up comedy material also uh i think they have access to our secure servers all right so we gotta do oh it's oh my god it's a medium do you think i'm ready guys Guys,
am I ready for medium difficulty?
Oh my gosh, that's a huge responsibility.
I brought overall up.
Also forgot how to hack, too.
So this is going to be interesting.
Oh.
Woo!
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Okay, this is bad.
I gotta figure this out.
Woo!
Oh,
shit.
Oh, wait.
Okay, I can kill him.
Okay, yeah, I forgot about that.
I forgot I could kill him.
Okay.
Guys, I hope you remembered that because I did it.
Alright.
Okay.
exit oh my god i can remember how to do all of this i don't okay um left right left okay guys what was the password because i don't remember okay up up down left right left what was it up up down uh left right left there you go there you go we get it wait that's medium i swear to god the easier ones were lot harder how the fuck was that medium hello yes it's that time of month again being the call you put up with this very frequent caller bro this caller just calls me to you know what i believe in depression man dip i believe in him guys because oh wait someone who can talk there you go all right there you go yeah your job is to talk to her and clean wait does anyone else have good stats for this no it's only him of course jack loves to talk the plays are hold down the fort okay let's get i mean she pays us to be fair she is a good subscriber so it's not i just make it look easy so late you're actually cool he's not he's just been gone all day so it seems like he is i'm saying that
that you know she does subscribe to us she's a tier 3 self she does buy the bonuses and everything and she tips very well so we might as well if her the job is just cleaning her house that's fine if someone dies because one of our heroes is cleaning the house maybe that guy that died should have been a tier three sub so he could have skipped the line the escape the fight between phenomena men the take down the trouble phenomena fan escort him oh my god guys the best way never meet your heroes understood
That's the best way to take care of it.
Never meet your heroes.
Especially when they're also especially when they're very fucking depressed, dude.
No, that's true.
And Purve, I'll just send her.
You know what I'll send.
Wait, who just said Phenomenon?
We'll give him a reality check.
Robert, on my home planet, when someone assumes your identity, and he's also very oh yeah we ain't getting this yeah you got injured fucking taco place from last night wait we did it okay were the tacos actually good or was it just 3 a.m yes what happened to it I think it was both oh he got depressed he got fucking depressed friends you had one job they were here fans and he didn't even i even went back that's crazy believes me but there's definitely a ghost in my house anybody over there good at exorcisms or whatever he got yeah he got depressed he's he's depressed as from he was gonna meet his fans and he's like he's like nah he literally kept with a meet and greet.
Now he'll really never meet him.
He'll never get his meet and greet.
Also, thank you for the ride.
Thank you.
Alright, investigate the supposed hauntish house.
Reassure the homeowner that she is not cursed.
Um.
Oh, by sending in the devil.
You know what?
Who is she friends with again?
Who is Melavola friends with?
I remember it says in the...
oh here sonar all right the best way the best way to investigate a haunted house um and to reassure the homeowner that is not cursed is to send in a fucking monster bat and a literal demon and be like don't worry ghosts aren't real but demons are well ghosts are bullshit but spirits are confirm we are hosting a little roast in the mayor and he came in it's a roast but be smart we don't want to be okay be smart oh i don't have okay prism is smart look at here there you go what's it going to be this and what could go wrong i don't write my own jokes can't we hire somebody there's a full-on gang war happening in the warehouse looks like a gang war red ring Lieutenant Prigoz understopped the gangs from Escalade.
Okay, so we have White Man.
And then we can have her.
You know what?
Let's get all of them.
Put everybody in.
It would be a shame if I had more stuff pops up.
Yeah, fight ghosts with demons.
We all know.
In rock, in rock, paper, scissors.
Oh, phone a friend.
There we go.
I knew the vibes were off this morning, but I couldn't tell if it was divorce vibes or shitty commute traffic vibes.
Hey, maybe she's not going to hell after all.
Marrying someone can send you to hell.
Yeah, what?
Yeah, but only if you marry a billionaire.
Ha!
Why?
But why?
Maybe the billionaire is the good person.
He made his money via very legal means.
Increasing success chance when...
Oh, nice.
I reached max synergy.
Let's go.
They sold their souls.
Maybe, but what if they do a lot of charity?
The faction of light needs your help to overtake the faction of darkness.
How did they role play as the hero that was foretold?
Okay, so it's just role play.
It stands for live action role play, but it's not a sex thing.
I mean, it can be.
People dressing up and playing pretend type shit.
Still sounds like a sex thing.
It can be.
You just heard about those conventions?
everyone oh this is bad everyone's resting i mean oh this is very bad assistance his line of delivery bots appear to have gained sentience and are attacking the city all right we have to take it here out of resting who would be the best to take it here uh okay so i was due i wait a All right,
here we go.
Role play as a hero that has foretold.
I'll assume...
I'm gonna take...
I don't know if I should take Sonar and put it...
Yeah, I'll take Sonar and put him in here.
That's good.
I know you're very...
You were...
You literally was in the Hunger Games.
You're gonna...
He was in the Hunger Games, guys.
Wait, I gotta check this.
Okay, we'll check this first.
Okay, nice.
Yeah, I think it was a little overkill, but yeah.
He's a very successful actor, so I think he's fine.
Alright, I swear to God, if it somehow goes all the way here.
Neh!
Okay.
Oh, shit, we have a lot of upgrades.
Okay, skill point.
We'll put...
You know what?
We need more intelligent people in our team.
I can't keep looking, putting it all...
I think we have enough combat and mobility.
But what if we put one more in combat?
Just what if, guys?
Okay, we'll put him in.
He's our all-rounder.
Okay.
Oh, shit.
Okay, we have to send someone here.
Stopped him before.
Okay, we'll do these two.
All right, I'm on it.
oh it has to be defense do we have anyone that's good on defense i'm the guy for it but you know i'll wait for like a little bit more okay he's gonna be not depressed soon there you go okay there we go we just got him okay there we go he's fine he's not depressed that guy all right i'll send you two in defrost the bank
Oh, I know the defense is Fresh out of depression, you're going back in Yeah Role play, I think these two can be Don't think it's cosplay When they see these two Alright, the yachts have taken over The mayors after The yachties, they're holding everyone's Hostage Now we have two of them for extra depression Rescue the hostages Before they get the ransom money It would just...
Wait, what's this?
More?
Okay, more.
You know what, more?
Alright, there you go.
I mean, that's fine, right?
We'll just hit all of you, fucking.
Um, you know what?
We'll do these two.
I think we're fine.
Alright.
Melt the ice, break the ice.
Let me fry them.
The ice, I mean.
God damn it.
Okay.
Send Flambay to the frost the bank without injuring the civilians.
okay i should have seen oh i should have oh whoops sorry we can't risk you burning traps um oh i should have noticed that before before flambay went out it's okay i have time 18 blazer's doing a speech over the college that's awkward one of you will be there to hear it all right uh we can wait a little bit not we don't have to oh well choose the class to lead oh a bard okay we have enough we do let's lead us a bard can't be that bad oh oh thank god i was gonna say i thought it was oh thank god i was like i have a i know i have 20 speech right now it's barred definitely i know because sonar went to harvard time to freak some out all right oh shit oh wait we're five yeah i I think I said yeah I definitely it was a little bit of overkill workday and I thought he could try using the forklift another certified forklift driver dropped entire shipment to recover what you can okay first off let us um you know what we'll put you on mobility um everyone keeps yelling at me to stop enhancing my
combat uh bro the kid wasn't forklift certified No fucking way.
He wants them destroyed, but I think there's a way to reprogram them.
Patch up to the retreating, then reprogram them to not attack humans.
Well, oh my gosh, we need someone smart, but we don't have that.
Fuck.
Oh, fuck.
Guys, why?
Why did I invest in combat?
Why?
There's some activity down in the sewers.
My tenants are getting uneasy.
Can you folks look into it?
Oh, this is bad.
I don't think Flamb is coming back in time.
It's okay.
I have depression, man.
And, um, be careful.
These two.
Wait, the odd couple.
It should be fine.
You aren't my typical romantic companions.
I could be persuaded.
We should be okay.
You know what?
No, we have to keep one of you guys up for the other task because...
Oh, this is bad.
This is...
No, he's not.
coming back in time guys he ain't coming back in time i have to it should be fine okay we have to keep the oh my god oh my god your team would fail would anyone not fail i have one two three who do i guys why did i invest in all the combat i mean i can't even do this all right so Some people are gonna die today.
Yes.
Some people are gonna...
Alright.
Sometimes things happen, okay.
Sometimes things happen.
I got it.
Okay.
We have to accept that thing.
Oh shit.
We can't save everyone.
The best towels.
I know.
I stole a few.
project maybe violence wasn't the answer I can't believe violence was not the answer I'm gonna send his or her ex-boyfriend to this uh hero training all right investigate the reports oh we'll send you two that'll be fine oh sure no like I thought you said you had it it had no one no one has that So happily gave up water boy.
Are you fucking?
Oh, thank God.
I've got the booze.
Um, yes, I gave up water boy for depression, man.
Because I will be happy to assist in transport if someone wished to fly over.
Because I can send him to his ex's, uh, to his ex's lesson to make it even more awkward.
Like, you don't get to do that with water boy.
Alright, let's see.
Okay, what I've learned.
that we have to stop putting it on combat what is what i learned today oh is he already maxed out unlucky are you kidding me are you no no don't do this to me no oh thank god oh thank god we Fuck you beat it.
See, you don't need fire.
All we get to do, we can just punch people.
That's fine.
But we'll have him learn something.
We might as well.
We don't have anything else to do.
How are you depressed?
We got a job well done.
How is your depression?
Have you just not been...
Have you thought about not being sad?
I'm a bad person.
just alright twice was set to max and removes rest time after stats dropped to one wait that's good that means less combat and reduce call completion if after it fails a third he is down yeah that's fine there's no way he's gonna fail again easy don't be sad
alright everything is fine oh I didn't get the bonus oh I did get the bonus.
Yay.
I'm sure we don't work on commission.
We did it.
I said my chemistry, people.
Oh, sonar require.
Engage in a diplomatic relations.
Win them over with...
Diplomatic has to be with, like, your brain, right?
And I maxed that out.
Oh, thank God.
I was gonna say, thank God.
I better max it out.
Yeah, we're friends with the MUD people!
Let's go!
See?
MUD people, MUD people.
Alright, let's have more smart people in our team.
Let's have a more combat.
Guys, what do we put in more combat?
Do you think I'll be a bad idea?
Yeah!
We're friends now!
I already have my max career, so it doesn't really matter.
matter how many I failed now like I can't get like super promoted because I you guys won't let me fuck the boss I could have had a I could have been promoted and a raise if you guys let me fuck my boss
Then why didn't you because we had a democratic vote and i ain't a corrupted leader yet You know, it feels like for the first time for that day i felt i felt kind today Which i'm sure you would appreciate been nice that we get to spend more time together right the team's more important the team might fuck up for a while the people's choice they're gonna get good that day i felt exceptionally bad than i ever could alone
but just when i feel like i got a handle on it got it figured out i think about chase and my dad and Shroud.
Then I get all fucked up.
You know what I'm saying, beef?
You know what I mean.
He's my emotional support animal.
Yeah, exactly.
See, this is why I appreciate her talks.
Wait, what the fuck?
Oh, hi.
What are you doing here?
Are you decent?
Definitely a house that needs some warmth.
Wait.
I'm in my underwear.
I am in my underwear.
What are you guys doing here?
I can see you.
I was joking when I asked if you're decent.
I know.
I just need you to know that I know how I look right now.
All right.
That rubs out, by the way.
You just have to put a little muscle into it.
Do you know the way you want to hang this?
You could have just knocked on my door.
I think he's only considered where he'd hang himself.
That corner seems fine.
Whoa, what the fuck?
for your housewarming party.
Oh.
I told people to bring a lamp or something.
Wait, wait.
More people are coming here.
This is going to be a party now?
Look, I'm not really...
My home's depressing.
Not what it looks like to me, but you're tidy whities.
Oh.
She just touched my...
This is your family photo area?
Kind of morbid.
Wish I'm kind of...
At least I had a family.
I'll go this too far.
Is that my work computer?
We figured it out, brother.
The man can be Mecca again.
Oh?
After your little premature Jack explosion, I had this feeling like I'd seen it before.
Then Vizzi asked me to get the energy reading we got this morning and cross-reference with recent calls.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
It's not destroyed?
Wait, what?
And a bunch of B-grade villains have been trying to unlock its power only to end up blowing their asses off like you did.
Then they sell it on the next sucker and the same shit.
Oh, so there's a...
Four times that we've tracked.
How does Shroud not know this?
Yeah, probably think like us.
I think it was destroyed.
how the fuck do people small fuck oh yeah i was gonna say surely he's like deeper in the villain which is why we're having a party villain society members know every low-level supervillain in three counties that's true we track its location they'll know who has it then we kick in some doors knock some heads snatch that back and you'll be pulsing thanks guys regardless of how this plays out yeah i feel like it could be a trap too because i feel like why is that so easy you know the last time someone did something so whoa god what is wrong with you just get gushy after we find the so i'm just trying to be nice with my boat over here in marina da re which is oh yari territory why she's here first you know much about those guys uh all money crew of ascot wearing coke heads skylal akate runs it now three generations that family's been trying to think of me what are they accusing you of you're cute we're gonna ask i wish i could date her but first rob gotta put on pants oh what but then i
can't do this yep right on that yeah harassment from my co-workers oh yeah sound guy has everything been okay so far for sound i know you said anything earlier about putting on my pants nice i know with my cat i can hook up with her why did they give me two choices kisses
oh hey more sonar
oh hey depression man he gave me a lamp as well oh pizza pizza party pizza time
I could okay I could try and hook up with Sonar and and her as well I don't think he has to be monogamous I make the choices for him it lamps for everyone oh my god get a table that's fine this was already gonna get striked I'm fine with that
Oh, he's fine with her ex now.
With his ex.
Oh, no.
He's hugging me.
That's like sex for him on his planet.
Oh, he saved it.
He shaved his depression.
Oh, he's not depressed anymore.
Oh, my God.
No.
Him!
God, Morsona has everything!
Rich, handsome, in the hunger gaze, and also hooking up with the devil lady?
God!
Thank you.
And he's a bad...
I'm so happy.
That's why he's the goat.
You do understand how projectors work, right?
Not more dramatic.
And bare walls are a sign of depression.
Why isn't always a warehouse by the docks?
It's where stuff comes in and stuff goes out.
It's that easy.
Not a rocket scientist, are you?
No.
Oh yeah, where is Flambay?
Yes, you're in.
He didn't come to my party!
That work is tricky.
my party.
That's more than shit.
You need a fucking army.
I'll go.
Can't shoot what you can't see.
Look, this is really great work, but doing this tonight is out of the question.
Hitting a secure location like this is something they would handle downtown.
Are you kidding?
There's enough firepower in this room to take down a fucking Kaiju.
Bunch of drunk ass Z-teamers, please.
Y'all wouldn't make it past the front door.
No one's asking you to do a goddamn thing, okay?
Hey, no need for that.
We have to be stealthy with all the cameras tomorrow night tomorrow night this thing's not gonna sit still for that long if make a plan first this is incredible viz but blazer's right we make a plan no need to rush this yeah I feel like I feel like it's a trap we go in now you understand that word or is it got too many fucking syllables for you why don't you go walk your ass around a mall grandpa heroes are talking you are no fucking hero whoa whoa chase you named yourself invisible bitch and you had it fucking right chase you're drunk you need to stop talking you want to get people hurt get people fucking killed back up chase that's my girlfriend chase that's enough i defend my queen even though i don't i didn't i wasn't on her side of her robert doesn't need to keep going out there with no powers putting his life on the line and make up for assholes like you he doesn't need to be mecha man I fight for my girl.
Wait, Robits?
Macamann?
What?
You're playing them?
You're playing yourself.
Wait, no, I'm Robbit.
I think you're invisible, but I fucking see you.
I'm Robbit.
Oh, no.
You don't know anything about me.
I know you're a liar.
Criminal.
I know you're fucking dangerous.
What else do I need to know?
Wait, wait a minute.
He docks me.
Wait, wait, chase.
Wait.
Oh, my God.
Wait, but I, guys, I'm rapping.
Guys!
That bitch sent his ass airborne.
How are you not dead?
You okay?
Chase, are you all right?
That's enough for tonight.
So shots?
I'm sorry, this turned into...
I got dots!
Anyone who utters one word about what happened tonight fucking answers to me.
Got it?
Oh no, is this plan big?
Oh, shit.
Oh, that's awkward.
I'm guys, guys.
The frogs.
From that thing, you know?
Oh, that's, it's okay.
I think he wasn't here, right?
I think he wasn't here.
It's okay.
What's up?
That's a red zone.
Sir, you can't park there.
Is that funny?
Did I make a funny joke?
Came back to apologize.
All these goddamn apartments look the same.
That guy watching us from the balcony walked into his house thinking it was yours.
Sorry about that.
Fuck you!
He said he was sorry.
Well, fuck you too!
Okay, let's just...
Oh shit, that's a crystal.
Is that Shugnight?
You sure this ain't vodka?
She told you.
Made quite a first impression.
Didn't know you would end up spitting in people's mouths.
Kinky shit.
It's that internet somehow made sense.
Isn't so bad for Doug?
You sound how you look.
Another thing I can't do anymore.
Fuck.
Maybe it's why I say the word so much.
Uh, sorry, Chase.
I hadn't thought about that.
I had a pretty good run.
You ever think about why we do what we do?
Yeah, I don't think I'm stopping my dog in his time soon.
put it all on the line for someone who won't ever know your name won't send you just how I'm wired bedside when you get hurt no no no it's how I'm wired I guess and here you are trying to rewire a bunch of criminals yeah what's wrong with that everyone deserves a second chance busy I was gonna walk off the team you know she's feeling low talking about how she was born with powers that always meant She'd end up as a villain.
Like he was fated.
I can see a picture.
So obviously I gave her the pep talk, you know.
Like, that's all bullshit.
You make up your own fate, yada, yada.
I don't even remember what I said, but I do remember thinking.
Oh, fuck.
Yeah, that must have been hard.
Like, if I didn't have you, you know, my dad.
Where would I have ended up?
You were always good.
That was always in you.
That's what makes us different from a thief like her.
Oh, come on.
You've stolen things too.
What?
You racist motherfucker.
I'm in the school.
Sorry, but you're- I need to blow my nose.
Give me a sec.
I should have laughed at that.
I didn't mean that in a racist way, bro.
I meant like, you know, you know, because you're young and you do reckless things.
Bro, Mega Man situation is crazy, bro.
Racial profiling from Mega Man?
Wow!
Getting that Google Dockey ridden.
Oh yeah, but that doesn't count.
That was for somebody else.
What, you quietly contemplating?
Yeah, I guess I hadn't considered some things.
But I think the answers are out there if you just listen to the wind.
i see why you and beat get along oh where's my guy oh i'm sorry my poor boy that's it there's my boy there's my good boy who's a good boy beef is
that's right oh oh invisibition's heading there
is there a mic on this hey hey can you hear me the fuck are you doing oh not much just looking for your stupid ass pulse that's somewhere on this big ass boat That's what she called herself.
Is that not what she called herself?
What do you call her that?
You know who's not good, beefy boy?
You know who's a real pain?
Fizzy?
What the dead name?
Oh, dead.
Sorry, I'm busy gal.
I thought she hated the busy gal, the name.
She was like, stupid and corny.
Something would be great.
Yeah, let's start with something.
Okay, it's okay, I'm not tired.
I could eat my steak a little bit.
My...
Or Vizzy.
I mean, she's doing something badass.
Bitch doesn't have to be derogatory.
Be like, sup, bitch.
I remember this.
Up, upright.
Wait, is that?
Up, upright, guys.
Remember that.
Out of range.
What does that mean?
Shit.
Need a password.
Up, up, up, up, right.
There you go.
Wait, there's nothing here.
Hey, I'm getting a huge energy reading coming from the captain's quarters.
Right.
And I'm supposed to know where that is.
See that tower?
The biggest one.
It's at the top.
Oh, perfect.
So you want me to cross this active battlefield?
Look, I didn't want you to do any of this shit.
I get it.
Okay.
Jesus.
Keep your eyes peeled for invisibility.
See?
She ain't said that.
They're on to me.
Oh, hey, there's a door to your left.
Where's the lock?
Oh, it's, um...
What's your name?
Oh my, I forgot her name.
It's been so long since we last saw her.
Oh, wait, no, never mind.
We're timed out.
Almost got it.
Okay.
Wait, how did... Okay.
oh there you go i got the i got the charge don't worry i got you girl oh shit
okay left left up right guys what was the password again left left left up right there you go guys like guys i just saw it but what's the password
oh it's a wing too big it's not her like I was looking at it it's like guys what was it oh it's a guy too lead him towards that speaker tower I've got an idea okay follow me feather dick I got something real cool to show you all right we have to figure out how to get down there at the tower do your thing working on it I'm trying my best.
Work faster!
I don't know what I'm doing!
There you go.
Uh, there you go.
Yeah, I have to grab electricity down here.
Oh, what?
Oh, no.
Okay.
Alright, there you go.
That should work, right?
I saved it!
Cover your ears Don't worry.
Oh my god.
We're so gonna hook up later If I if I make you oh my god
Yeah, good night Fuck me.
How am I supposed to get around that look hey just worry about not dying.
I'll find you a way around
These years are bad see guys.
I told you investing cut investing in combat was a good idea but not the time don't keep focus i am so focused oh oh oh my need just pushing through guys remember this reminding me
okay we got one of them away okay um okay oh god guys guys what was the password i forgot what's the What's the password?
What's the password?
Left, left, left, right.
There you go.
Now the crane.
I don't do well when I'm panicking.
Whoa.
Oh, shit.
The captain's quarters should be right in front of you.
Watch this.
Oh.
Tell us where the pulse is.
Invisibitch before we go full Pompeii on your ass.
Full Pompeii on my ass?
What kind of threat is that?
You're gonna give me diarrhea?
Wait, don't.
That was predictable.
What do we do when she's invisible?
That is such an overpowered...
That is so overpowered.
It's in the safe.
The safe?
I don't know how to open a fucking safe.
Wait, hard attack?
Wait, no.
Alright.
What do you mean hard attack?
Successive, but...
Okay, guys.
Hurry up.
Come on.
Oh.
I was like, come on, guys.
Hardest hack.
Never mind.
I spoke too soon.
It's just like, guys, come on, really?
There you go.
All right, shit.
There's no more.
All right, that's fine.
I don't know what I did here.
Okay, encryption key collected.
Okay.
Wait, did he respawn?
Okay, there you go.
It's fine.
We're fine.
Okay, now...
Okay, is it in there?
Okay, it was...
I was literally playing Pac-Bat.
Uh, you know what?
I guess it does.
Okay.
why did stop wait what wait you're right wait what shit are they oh shroud what's going on our creator's time just hang on trying to get the camera back online i see you is this shroud you're good just take one step at a time
just go invisible
oh stop shroud behind you oh why the fuck don't you Just go invisible!
He's right behind her, isn't he?
Hey, Vizzy.
Stay calm.
Your inhaler is...
A few feet in front of you, okay?
You gotta get to it.
Oh,
that's why she always has trouble.
No!
Hey, Vizzy, he's just gonna keep fucking with you, but you don't give up, okay?
Oh, she can't go invisible with the power.
Oh, the thing is still freezing.
Bro, she can't freeze.
You get up.
Get up.
Oh, no, he has to go.
Keep up.
No!
He's gonna die!
Chase!
Okay, yeah, you're good.
He's gonna have a heart attack.
How much did he age?
Oh, no.
Do you have a heart attack?
Oh, why is anyone calling?
Why did I run out of self-calling 911?
What the fuck am I gonna do?
Oh, my God.
You only wanted to wait and make a plan.
Oh, yay, I'm the majority.
You helped him.
Yay!
We did, we helped him.
Dan said, you and Forfeited posed in the Mechaman.
We didn't really have a lot of hard choices.
We failed to deal with the delivery parts.
Yeah.
Yay!
We became friends with a...
Yeah, played as a bard.
Yay.
Let's try with being a bard.
Oh, wait.
I am 9-1-1.
Oh, you're right.
Yay, my most said hero.
For better than 60%.
I forgot.
I am 9-1-1.
How?
What do I do when I'm 9-1-1?
The week after this episode felt so loud.
Oh, yeah.
You guys have to wait a week after.
because they released episode 7 and 8 a week after that's why I waited you know all my friends they were like you gotta play dispatch I was like oh wait I hate this is why I hate episodic shit I fucking hate episodic like content because like there's like a cliffhanger and then you have to remember what happened like in the last episode and everything to like when you're especially if the episodes take very long to release because that was basically the walking dead The Walking Dead took so long to release in between episodes.
So, it's like, so, like, people have, they always have to have a recap and everything.
But, and then I was, like, telling my friends, I was like, I'm going to wait until everything is done.
So I can just play, play, play, play.
And I hate me.
Collaboration with Critical Role.
Is Chase dead, dead?
Come on, Chase.
You're not.
I'm too old to be crying.
You're not dead, right?
fuck off no you're not i cry all the time is that chase really when when i was your age i cried for weeks when the raiders left la classy chase right totally the fucking same as my dad never being home whoa motherfucker language and it was the same my pops had season tickets growing up seats sucked but i just like being there with them so yeah when they moved i was crying like a little bitch too this before he age like a bitch yes bitch that's exactly what i'm saying what do you want from the store your dad gave me a hundred and i gotta break the shit anyway he pays you fuck yeah he pays me now come on what was this what was my dad's job i want a cigar i'm trying to go broke every time you get lonely can i get a swisher thing the fuck you want with a swisher isn't that what you and dad smoke right yeah uh yes that that is what we smoke fine but don't share it with your dad but didn't my dad do it for free no I thought my dad did it for free like me or was he also a subscriber
yeah oh so he didn't do it for free I did oh there bitch you happy now Yeah!
Smoking!
Don't smoke, guys.
Take a deep breath.
You know.
That was my grandpa, not my dad.
That was part of the superhero team.
Yeah, teaching children how to smoke.
Your favorite.
I didn't realize you two are that close.
I bet it.
Teach him young.
Oh, he's alive.
He was like a brother.
He was like a big brother to me.
I didn't appreciate it enough.
I'm sorry.
Chase had only babysit nights when Dad had to deal with something big.
Working late, he called him.
I was fine being alone, but I had still asked to have and watched me because i could guilt trip him into buying me shit dude thank you for super chatting thank you and happy birthday we'll sing you a happy birthday soon dude after you know the guy after like the dying guy is gone so maybe one less door run for bitch ass robert and he wouldn't be stuck in here that's what you're saying right i mean it was but now that
person that put Chase here.
Pending the investigation, Invisigal suspended.
Obviously, but I think you should consider cutting her from the team.
No!
I'm not saying you should.
I'm just saying you should consider it.
Might make things worse.
I'm keeping her.
I'm using all my power to keep her in.
That might just make things worse.
No!
That's my girlfriend.
It's just...
I can't help but think that we've already cut a hero for far less.
Yeah, but she didn't want to fuck me.
That's different.
Yeah, nepotism.
Just gets better and better.
Vending machine.
The true.
Whatever I want.
Yeah.
See, if I hooked up with the boss, she would have given me a $100 allowance.
He told me that.
Oh, really?
He's proud of me?
Instead of just $5, I could have got $100.
Oh, I'm sorry, Chase.
Robert.
Twinkie money.
It's not about the money, Thurkey.
It's about power and promotion.
Oh.
Got Twinkie, though.
Oh, she gave me a shitty dollar.
Not even flat.
She made me crumpled up my $5.
Water, boy.
I just realized it's...
What's his name?
The YouTube...
The guy who does, like, those types of animations.
Where...
Where you, like, trace over...
Do we...
Yeah.
where you use like live action footage.
Yeah, Joel Haver.
I love that guy.
I love his animation.
He was also in Smiling Friends, but the fuck you save him.
But like he, his animations on YouTube is so good.
We have rotoscoping.
He used roto.
He used like not specific.
Yeah, so he used like rotoscoping animation mixed with like, what was it like the new AI feature in the Photoshop?
I'm a little mad too.
I can't.
can't it's not not fair in Visigal was the one who and then Chase shouldn't have
oh do you think he did the right thing I mean I don't it seems very not clear or unclear I think he did I think Chase knew he was the only one who could save her and he knew the risk so yeah i think it was ultimately the right thing he died for a villain so so that means she's redeemable
yeah twinkie oh case in point whoa
feel better kind of i'll clean it up what the fuck Like, did she have a crush on Chase or something?
Like, what kind of reaction was that?
Hey.
Waterboy is the Reaper build.
Some version of what happened.
Let's get to it.
Main takeaways are that Invisagal has been suspended.
So we're a person down the shift.
And that Chase is in the infirmary.
And he's in pretty rough shape.
despite his disposition.
No, he's depressed again.
Just don't tell him I told you that.
Oh.
I've found doing something good always helps when I'm feeling bad.
We're fortunate to have that opportunity.
Something Chase never took for granted.
So, let's get to work.
I guess there's like no off these years.
I guess you don't really have off day when you're, you, when everyone's always calling 9-1-1.
I mean, what do you do when like you're calling 9-1-1 and you're like, sorry, we're on a holiday?
Like, what the fuck do you do?
Also, Duke, happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Duke.
Yay.
Happy birthday.
Also, Cap and Romeo, the mistyper, thank you.
Thank you.
Sleep a tea key for free items exactly exactly yeah i guess you just die like like you have an emergency during new years and we're like sorry we are could really use some help getting them back it doesn't move them as fast okay we'll send depression man two depression men don't worry prism is slowly walking over there thanks to the structural reinforcement the damage to the resort is Not as bad as it could have been.
Evacuate, there is identify the structural integrity.
Wait, okay, what are the others' favorite?
Okay.
Oh, Depression and Jack are best friends.
Oh my God, I could have sent them together.
I didn't realize.
Oh, Golem has no friends.
Sorry.
Oh, wait.
Oh, no, Golem's friends went and visit Gal.
Busy.
I should send these two together more.
I mean, I could send Flam.
Oh, I can't.
I keep sending the other two.
Upchuk's rugby team lost, and he's throwing a very toxic acid is acid vomit is using the rain to rain tear use necessary force oh necessary force um wait why why don't you want to do that what do you hate me what oh yeah i'm sure why don't you want to do this i feel like i have to use punch up and wait why is he depressed Are you sad if she's gone?
No, you come in.
I tell you.
This is your job.
I mean, yeah, I think so.
We're going to do these two.
I know this guy.
I used to have more hair.
Bro, this is your job.
She's going to come back.
Identify the structural.
I'll send them these two.
Put the synergy up.
They're all busy now.
Oh, it's just hacking.
It's fine.
Man, why are you all sad?
I don't...
Oh.
Is this...
Oh, it does.
It zaps it for me.
That's good.
Just stop being sad, guys.
Okay.
Oh.
All right, we got him zapped.
Remember this.
Left, right, right, right, left, right, left.
Okay, remember this, guys.
Left, right, right, left.
Yeah, I need him to be let here.
There we go.
Whoa, whoa!
Okay.
How did he get closer to me?
That's crazy.
I was like, bro, you're supposed to...
like kill him not to bring him closer bad touch whoa buddy whoa back away be no good yeah living on the edge but you know oh what's that i know this guy wait wait man i know this guy but um can you go talk to him yeah i'm really antivirus who if you ever got around to adopting that dog nice he knows buddy all right see column you had to make more friends oh yeah no we didn't overkill on that
all right nice now everyone's just resting and then we need to see he's there okay this should be fine right oh shit yeah it should be fine yeah let's go Did I see...
Did someone said...
More combat?
See, look, guys, I restrained myself from more combat.
Golem?
Golem, what are you doing?
What?
Oh, Golem's shitface.
I think he's about to piss mud on the high school.
Oh, no, he's super drugged.
Don't worry, I can heal you.
I didn't think that was weird.
Come on, buddy.
There you go.
You're better now.
guys i gave him a band-aid i get it i want to get ship faced right now more than anything but we got a job put a band-aid over his mouth just hang in there until the end of the shift after that you can do whatever the fuck you want cool cool can someone please go get golem before he does more property damage all right we did it oh no save golden from the carrying him back claim
too does that require intelligence calming people down chat i just want to make them more better friends maybe i mean i could you know i'll send him to because i need more intelligent people i not really okay i'm just gonna send all three of them in so that i can just because i need them to not be a we have too many with too many unga bunga teammates right now here who controls bugs apparently they have beef with one of our farmers using pest decides.
It's getting real biblical down here.
Take down the bug controlling.
Save the former from being attacked.
I mean, I could do this.
I cannot do that.
Um, we'll just wait a little bit.
We'll just...
I realize I can't just do that.
Um, oh, oh, this is interesting.
Um, she's more intelligent.
Uh, We'll do...
I don't know.
Do we need combat for this or...
No, Flambay.
No, Flambay is too strong.
Oh, wait, no, he's fine.
This has to be...
Do we need... It's speed?
Okay, we'll do this.
It's fine.
See?
This is...
This is 10, right?
Yeah, he's fine.
There you go.
Flambay, go in there.
Flang's a bitch.
You can't see shit.
make him fly in the rain god damn slip and slide i fucking love slipping yeah golem's okay now and they're better friends i like it he's sober that's how you fix sobriety um we'll do mobility we'll make you fast as boy
we are he finishes he's he heals up so fast all right i don't know what the percentage is for this Oh, yeah, we did it.
Nice.
We've arrested a bug lady.
Is she, like, hot, though?
Like, the one-punched man bug lady?
Bone Zone pissed off the wrong gang, and they're holding him hostage.
In the bone zone?
Listen, I know he sucks, but he writes my checks.
Can you please just rescue him?
There you go.
We got you.
Wait, are they all really...
Are they... Okay, level two?
And I'm going to try raising up Prism and Flamb and Depression Man and Jacksepticeye.
Hi, just calling to confirm one of your Z-Team heroes for our interview this afternoon to discuss the Phoenix program.
Oh, okay.
Will you sonar?
He's going to have public speaking.
What's this?
I'll bet Golem in there.
I really think it can help the team too.
Another one?
Terrence?
Let's learn.
Oh, shit.
We can't.
Um, I gotta send sonar in here first.
Um, yeah, I think, ah, I want to, I'll, I want to send him in, but the thing is, I need him to do this first.
Hello.
So, I'll do that later.
I'm running late at the airport.
I zoned out there for a second.
Escort the mayor's assistant to look for the flight.
Okay, that has to be mobility.
I have that in here.
That's fine.
Wait.
Let's do this first.
Alright, what did you get?
Expands to fill each increasing stats by up to 200%.
Oh!
Now we can do this.
We'll do this.
I like that.
We don't need to... Yeah, I think he can... Yeah, one seems really, really strong in general.
Alright, what's this?
Oh yeah, I would have no fucking ace that shit.
Prism's power but it's so strong.
double up expand of red rings coordinating strikes across torrents oh talk up the reform villains finally his degree is worth it now stick to the talking points finally i'm literally a professional bullshitter and that's how it's fucking done i knew his degree okay if i miss that flight i'm fucking toast red rings coordinating strike cross looks like they are okay but which one's this chance to get payback go all out bring them a fight and make them pay for what they did to chase get hurt okay we'll do that uh escort the mayor's assistant to the airport before the flight wait who should we i want to fight them so i need guys who do we put for this running late golem solo okay we'll do golem solo then golem for this solo what do we do flambe we put flambe here Is it speed and defense?
Okay, Flambay's solo.
We'll do that.
All right.
And then flight license.
Yeah, we don't have anybody.
Okay, we're going to have to play it safe.
Listen, we need to play it safe.
No, we're going all in.
I'm sending...
Oh, shit.
Oh, I know what to do.
Get in!
Oh, wait.
Returning.
Okay, wait for her to return.
And then I know what to do.
All right, coffee time.
You coming back.
All right, depression!
Both depression, man.
And then there's no way, I swear to God, if we fuck up with intellect, I swear to God, if it's intellect that we are missing, the one point of intelligence, I swear to God, I swear to God, there's no way I can fail this.
Oh, nice.
was just speed.
Yeah, like the one person belly.
There we go.
If he dies, he'll be taken care of.
Yeah, that's nice to know.
More mobility.
Trust me.
I don't think...
Girl, what the fuck even are you?
Alright.
Oh.
This fucking rain is flooding our neighborhood.
We need this water gone.
Move quickly before the flooding.
some investigate what could cost oh we need speed fuck um we'll put another in speed but we need speed though like do we want which one do we want guys is an all-arounder do we want intelligence or charisma
or like all-rounder brain middle solo golem and center okay god okay solo golem and center oh shit oh my god spread fin okay I can send sonar to learn how to fly alright learn how to fly yeah nice there's no way I swear to god I swear to god in my food I can Oh my god,
Waterboy's not even in the team!
Okay, what do you mean, Waterboy?
He's just a janitor!
Okay, do we fetch...
What does fetch the bucket or examine the storm drain for clogs?
It's...
I mean, we're all around here.
I feel like it doesn't matter which one I do.
Bro, he's just...
He's not even this.
Oh, shit.
Never mind.
Yeah,
no.
I guess some people died.
Fuck, man.
We said less water, not more.
Rescue civilians navigate.
Oh, sorry.
Sorry, man.
How the hell is I supposed to know it's 10 speed?
Okay.
Yeah, thank God.
I was going to say I swear to God.
I'm in some of the 1% of the time.
intelligence.
Wait, you're depressed?
But you made a friend.
Wait, what was the entire...
Okay.
How are you depressed?
You have a friend!
You're leveled up!
We need backup down here.
There's a mass pile up in the tanker caught fire.
Okay.
The fire is growing.
Okay, flamb.
We'll use fire.
to put out fire that's how it works right but he learns how to fly now right uh turner flies to cause with greatly reducing and care also carries not oh nice okay oh shit flambe flambe is my fastest character and oh my god
I can't send him in.
What are you talking about?
I'm trying to think right now.
Okay, because I can only send one of them in.
I either send Flambe here or...
There's no...
Nobody's going to come back in time.
I think I have to send...
I'm sending Flambe to fight fire for fire.
Yeah, I'm sending him in.
He's going to...
We're going to fight fire with fire.
Let's go.
And then there's nothing else I could do.
She's the only one here.
Yeah, it's fine.
The room's booked, yeah?
Yeah, confirmed it this morning.
We're all good.
That's how it works.
I want to see you all there.
Someone's going to fuck up.
Oh, shit.
okay okay okay apparently the fire versus okay fire versus fire strap was not it who would have known pray to rng oh my god what is this what the fuck is this rng all right so several people have died today it's okay they just didn't they missed their subscription yet let's just say they missed subscription okay team good shift all things considered see you tomorrow hopefully with some good news
now okay yeah Twinkies oh no my my goy steak finished it all okay only 50 people dead today I Guys, I lowered my record.
My lowest yet.
Wait, why are you guys fighting?
Your personal best.
Damn.
You want a part of that I thought?
What are y'all looking at?
You've got a little...
Oh.
Cheers, lad.
Good looking out.
Just paying for this.
Okay, who's gonna pay for this?
Hey, I'm the one that caused the damage.
With what?
With them.
Aw.
Okay.
Cool.
Now that we got all of the details clear.
Why?
That's just a difference of opinion.
I got heated.
Got in Golem's face.
He had every right to punt me through the wall.
Right.
It's a door and I got you were actually in his face.
More like ankle.
Which made him easier to kick.
What the fuck is going on?
We want her out.
What?
Basically took a board vote.
That's why we're in the board room.
Why you're voting in these out?
I'm neither human nor reformed villain.
Nor particularly interested in this conversation.
I only came in as I thought we were playing Magic the Gathering tonight.
I am hoping we still may.
Who wants you to stay?
Just me.
Oh.
But the team is more important than any one of us so.
I won't stand him away.
You could have led with that.
We heard about the suspension bullshit.
It ain't enough, Robert.
Not for what she did.
To put everything we've been building at risk, and for what?
For me.
I like the bitch, but she gotta go.
And by go, we mean cut.
Just like you cut, Koop.
I'm gonna defend her!
But that's what it is.
I'm defending her, I don't care.
Look, I probably don't say this.
She did it for me!
But I'm...
We're a family!
And I'm fucking here!
Soon!
A few months ago, you wouldn't have been...
I'm already committed!
I'm discussing the needs of the Z team.
And if you did...
If I can't have muscle mommy, I'll have her.
Soon.
But I'm not cutting this ago.
It was before bros.
We lift them up, and I believe of her, what I believe of all of you, that her heart is in the right place.
It's what took us from being a team to being this weird, fucked up family.
Look you're hurting.
Okay, I get it.
I'm hurting.
We are all hurting.
Good speech, Robert.
Now isn't the time.
Better speech than what the speech I was going to do.
It's the time to come together and heal.
Aww.
Moral has dropped?
What do you mean?
That was a good-ass speech!
What the fuck do you mean, Moral has dropped?
Ohana means family!
Ohana.
Lizzie?
Sorry.
i can come back why first time we met you were in your underwear fitting right last time you see me that i'd be in mine oh yes i really do appreciate you defending me but you shouldn't i care about you they don't want me here i care about you courtney whoa no no in the risks what you were willing to put on the line i care about you girl yeah she went she did all that for me I'm willing to put myself out of that.
Because he cares about you.
And he's not the only one, so please don't throw all of that away by walking away from this.
First name, that's for you.
From us.
Fuck, from me.
Please.
They're right.
I don't deserve anyone's forgiveness.
Anyone's help.
Anyone's love.
I love you, though.
Because I can never repay it.
Nothing I do will ever make up for what I've already done to you.
I don't need you to repay.
Maybe the Astral Pulse back would help, but I couldn't even do that.
Vizzy, you don't owe anyone anything, okay?
Least of all me.
I was there that night.
What are you saying?
What?
Oh!
I said my own thing, but my asthma was getting worse, and they had an augment that could increase my life.
Bro, what?
You play Xbox Two?
YouTube please But she also plays Xbox
She was part of the game It is from this where she decided That being bad is bad She didn't do it a mecha man undetected
wait she's the one that put the bomb good news buddy trout says he just wants the astral pulse which we all know isn't really yours anymore yeah oh it was never about me
so every all the red so they all knew about her oh and then she saw me and she's like wait he's cute I can't kill him I know.
She let her...
Okay guys, okay.
She let her pussy talk.
I quit the moment I placed it.
I walked out before it even blew.
My augments conveniently stopped working.
Oh.
So I signed up for the Phoenix program the next day.
We had...
Oh, because she didn't kill her.
You just gave me the chance to fuck your life up twice.
I forgive you.
Well, I forgive you.
So there, we fucking chill out now.
Tokyo is so degenerate.
You fucking forgive me?
You haven't even, like, processed what's going on.
You did villain shit while you were a villain.
Does it change things that you dropped without me?
I forgive you, though.
That's in the past.
You're not the same person that was there that night.
Neither am I.
That's sweet, but...
I feel numb.
Hey, stop making this feel like a goodbye.
Okay, you're suspended.
It's temporary.
I'm not letting anyone cut you.
All I wanted from this was for you to look at me the same way you look at Blazer.
What?
What if it was just once, you know?
I don't look at Blazer.
I don't know what you mean by that.
What?
You do.
I chose...
Sorry, my chat chose you over Blazer.
So, come on, girl.
What the fuck do you mean?
Oh, like a hero.
Oh, sorry.
I thought you meant something.
Oh!
Whoa!
Oh, like a hero.
Lean in.
Oh, shit.
Oh, my God.
Everywhere.
Why the fuck would I lean out?
This was all I fucking I put my career on the line I put my career on the line and keep her on the team I might as well lean in This was what I was building for
Here's tree Don't worry the censorship will save me Alright boy you boys Don't stay up too late
HR violation Let's go I'm facing you Super chat.
Thank you.
Press that story on SDN here.
I got hurt last night.
Can't tell them it was Trackstar.
I want people to know what Chase did, but I don't know how he'd feel.
Or should I say it was Invisigal.
They messed up when we got to her.
So it wouldn't be a lie.
Invisigal.
I just feel like, oh my gosh, she types.
Like, in...
Wait, why Trackstar?
Okay.
Is it Trackstar?
it would be a better ending because my first thought was in visit yeah chase is the hero yeah but like but i feel like if we do it for busy then uh you dox you you dox
but i can sip all the way
Okay, we'll do...
We'll do track start.
Docks for a docks, exactly.
Feel the same way, thank you.
Docks maxing.
I mean, I hope they all die.
I'm serious.
into a trap that fucking stupid should have the plug pulled right now just pillows over faces oh man have you seen what the poison does to their faces they get all red and puffy oh oh that's me i'm back at the villain bar i'm sorry it's my fault i've been distracting you give me another drink give me another drink i smashed mine sure you all right you seem perturbed Oh,
fuck.
I know what's going on.
Kid probably lost someone there.
That's why he's been staring at that shit all night.
Get him a drink on me.
Wait, is that Shroud?
He looks too normal.
Nah.
This one's on me.
Shroud, that's you?
Why are he at the villain bar?
It has to be Shroud.
Like, he looks way too normal to be in a villain bar.
And he looks like a goddamn nerd.
Oh, oh my.
Yeah, he looks like a villain.
Yeah, I'm like, you have to be a villain to be at a villain bar.
And, like, he looks way too normal.
And he looks like a fucking nerd.
Only Shroud is a nerd.
Get fucked.
What?
Cheers, fellas.
dream it's like everyone else in this bar is like make it up and then there's this fucking gal glasses this nerd can you motorboat an ass and he's all too what's up you don't like asses let it go I gotta get close to I gotta get close to shroud right real quick with this guy I have to let it go so if I put too much of uh if i too much put too much commotion then he's gonna get away okay now i don't know what he's talking about freckles you mind telling me what's going on oh i
respect her blazer real superhero oh i know we're in a villain bar but have some class you know
if you're gonna blow some fuckers brains out non-slip mats are a must for the hideout.
Feel silly calling you to hideout.
Can you take care of him for me?
Obviously, you two don't need an introduction.
With pleasure.
Oh, shit he knows!
Oh!
You.
Your dad.
Troud?
I fucking knew, Allison!
Why is this nerd in the village bar?
It has to be shroud.
This old-ass nerd.
I fucking knew it!
There's no solving human nature.
I damn knew that was him.
Fucking nerdass.
All you can do is control it.
Oh, fuck.
I believe him, boss.
If he had something to say, he would have said it by now.
I thought you wanted revenge.
This was your father's gun.
Kept it in his locker.
Fully loaded.
Six shots.
He couldn't have predicted I'd use it to kill him.
The first bullet grazed his shoulder.
I hadn't had dusted to the adrenaline spike.
Wait, is that fired sooner?
Would he join the crowd?
Bro, what?
He's lying on the floor or I was full of fear when I put the floor through his face.
A bit of a waste to put the fifth through that idiot's skull, but I wanted to make sure it worked after all these years.
What the fuck is Sodenar gonna do?
Talk me to death?
Your father was the last person to touch this bullet.
And now, there's a 16 and a half percent chance it touches you next.
Your invisible girlfriend stole my astral pulse to give it to you.
Where the fuck is it?
I don't... She's still...
I'm gonna spit in his face.
I'll control this.
gonna kill you that's cute that's right do it this is why i hate luck if i had it wide i let you stream me about a fucking pinata she didn't get the pulse i won the gotcha yay i trusted my gotcha odds you actually believe that
What?
Invisibitch has the pulse that I know.
What I don't know is why she didn't give it to you.
She played you too.
Here I am thinking she's working with you, but she's fucking with you both.
She didn't take it for you.
She took it for herself.
No, she did it to protect me.
No, I don't trust you.
She fooled me too.
No, she did it to protect me.
I love this strike.
Oh, shit.
That's my girl.
What's this?
Oh, Blazer.
Dad.
See that?
It says dad on the top.
The blonde Blazer.
I fired the bartender, but I can still get you something to drink.
No, thank you.
Into what do I owe the pleasure?
I'm here for him.
In five minutes, this bar will be surrounded by SDN agents, heroes, and whoever else you in your ring have pissed off recently, which happens to be every gang in Los Angeles.
Now, if...
bluffing what sorry about that if they weren't you wouldn't have cut them oh you were saying but why is he giving her a tip off why is she giving her tip that eventually I would fall but by my read I'm taking a lot of you with me oh so all of you can leave now or half of you can die here
horrifying that's a fucking superhero chills top-notch you made them nervous okay we're out of here take your piss-soaked pants out the back please don't want to tempt this tiger
now's not our time blazer but it's coming sooner than you think oh and by my calculations it was closer to 32 percent but half sounds better yeah she rounded up guys
guys look there's no there's wait canva's Well, I wouldn't know how she found me first.
How'd you know?
Find me.
Yeah.
I tracked your phone.
Sorry.
I'll never forgive you.
Oh.
She's a stocky.
Okay.
I know.
Ring, ring, ring.
I got another write-up for you.
Another citation.
She got you pretty bad.
Okay.
Hmm.
Are you sure he's right about him?
Phenomenal.
I saw the footage.
What is her play?
Why wouldn't she tell you if she has it?
Okay, first of all, why are you tracking me?
I don't understand what she would want it for unless...
I trust her.
I trust her!
She's protecting me!
What matters is...
I trust her.
I think you're more optimistic.
I think they fired HR.
you're probably right
just need to sit here for like a few weeks then I'll be right as rain take your time I don't know how you're conscious see when the pain's constant yeah but she cuts the first thing that went was h.i used to that goes for physical and emotional really is nice up here thank you don't remember if i've thanked you before but about 50 times you were muttering it the whole flight then i take it back you should know i was going to take you to the actual hollywood song oh wait can i kiss her too oh
have you heard about polygamy miss blazer wait what what are What the fuck is going on?
Greed.
Wait, what?
Oh shit!
Why the helicopter?
What the fuck?
Okay, to be fair, 50% of them are SDN subscribers, so we only have to stay 50% of the town.
Bro, that guy's a flasher.
You're not leaving me here again.
Can we not have a superhero that can, like, heal?
Like, is that not...
That power not exist in this fucking world?
GG's no support.
Honestly, yeah, I'm like, GG's no support.
Yeah.
Nice.
Yay!
We're all simps.
Forgive her.
Yay!
We're all thinking of our peepies.
Yippee!
Yay!
40 thoughts win again!
Yeah, you at 10% chose a cigar.
Damn, right.
The real majority.
Okay, 46% did it as salt the barn.
Yippee!
We all smoky!
Okay, rescue golem.
Chose to go out.
Yeah, we all chose to beat up the red ring.
Now, man, you perform better than 20%.
Because he's phenomenal.
No, I've never smoked in my life.
My dad smoked.
In Asia pot smoking is like uh of norm like you could in back then you can i i think i don't know you can still can but like you could smoke in restaurants like they have like each table will have a smoking tray thank you depressed man but
now i think everyone just vapes now i think vaping is a lot more dangerous can you can make it taste like cotton candy
Oh, nice.
He's making him bellies.
His name's Mr. Whiskey.
Yeah, I'm very sure, like, vaping is a lot worse.
Oh, hello.
Oh, oh, yay!
He saved it.
Thank you.
That's, uh, your lifesaver.
Did he not go home?
I don't think he went home.
I think he went straight to work.
Bro, what?
The report coming in from the refinery multiple augmented villains breaking containment Dispatch all available heroes in the area boss.
We don't have any heroes in the area.
What can you handle things here?
Where are our heroes?
I Just think I need to get out into the field for us to have a shot.
Wait.
Oh my god.
Go.
We got you covered.
We got you Oh shit the tablet keep an eye on the feed Stay don't save anyone I was tempted to pick say just to say Don't say people stay here I was this close Honestly Oh he's still not bad My type been not the best Stay let them die We can use whatever you can give
Yeah what there's only three What happened What you mean is this it?
Bitch you know what time it is I didn't mean it like that.
Thanks for getting out of bed or whatever you were up to.
Yeah, I'd say come here to fall asleep, so I might be just a little.
Are you gonna finish your sentence, big man?
Hmm?
Yeah.
Oh no, he's fucking out of it.
Look, we're shorthanded.
Technically for it with Prism.
We should have the rest of the team trickling in, so we'll have to make do for now.
Lucky for us, we got the best three heroes on the roster.
We all know you'd say the same shit about whoever was weird.
Like if we all know, then there's no reason to point it out.
Also, like, doesn't prison have concerts to do?
Like, I thought being a pop star makes you, like, extra busy.
Like, I feel...
Oh, wait, what happens?
Oh, I guess there's...
Oh, whoa, oh!
Jesus!
Red Ring swarming all over the fucking city!
First things first, yes, half the team is missing.
Let's fix that immediately.
Next, LA is on fire.
Okay, we'll work on that third thing.
Okay, but when is LA not on fire?
It's losing out of every crack in the city.
Damn, dog.
That's a lot of things.
It is a lot of things, but nothing we can't handle.
So, I need you guys to focus.
Shit's only going to get worse if you don't.
You with me?
I mean, true, but...
Was there a forest fire like last year?
Clear Red Ring Grooves Protected Defenseless Employees.
Okay, oh.
Red Ring just released an experiment from containment.
It's a big thing.
we'll just do we are crushing it baby what do we want wait i should look at the other ones too this year but also last year and also the year before that and also isn't that what we pay sdn for we're not evacuating okay you can keep them coming yeah okay we are we need to evacuate so you all right so i'll put you should he be on middle okay middle all right You go solo this We're gonna try and figure out Doubles out there already,
but there's so many whether the package is a threat and dispose Shit, okay dispose of the determine whether okay, you're not that smart.
So I don't know I'm gonna put you on this suspicious package outside of City Hall Please send someone to investigate bomb squad is tied up Yeah, this is intelligence, but she's not that smart
She's not that smart.
She's my second smartest, which isn't saying much, guys.
It's...
Oh yeah, her morale is down because I was like, no.
Oh, shit.
Oh, no!
We're not gonna evacuate!
See that bar on the top left?
That's Torrance.
Or what's left of it?
Oh, shit.
It's okay.
That mayor, Mr. Yao, he's not getting re-elected.
All right, everyone.
You should get live updates on the state of the city.
Let's kick some red ring.
It's fine.
That means that mayor is going to get impeached, guys.
That's okay.
Oh, my God.
Oh, home.
Are you fucking getting me?
There's no time for this.
Okay.
Don't worry.
You're better now.
this is fine or at least that one works because the mayor was like we're not evacuating even though half the city was burning so that's on him these golems got me thank god um combat okay no combat no combat i can't keep doing combat okay i have to send i'm just gonna send two I think it's sent to here.
Alright, we gotta be successful.
You're trying to step to me.
Wait, someone's tracker is freaking out.
We'll do that hacking thing that you do.
Alright, it's hacking time.
Uh, react.
Hi!
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Alright, this is gonna be scary.
Because it's a high hack.
I've never done a high one before.
Oh, fuck off.
Ah, you kidding me?
Oh, my God.
Yeah, I need him to be here.
That's right.
I got you now.
Zap, zap, bitch.
Alright.
Come on.
Wait, that was high?
Oh, okay, yeah.
No, that makes sense.
Never mind.
out of range I was like bro why the fuck was that one high no I get it
does it not go anywhere oh it's right side okay that's right okay I need to go back I'm going back I'm going back warmer
what yeah nearly there Yeah!
Okay, that's interesting.
I found it.
All right, did I do it?
Oh, he's, thank God we just got 100.
Oh, this is so scary.
Don't be.
We don't know what's going on in the refinery or what's happening to Flamboy.
Don't know what the fuck are we waiting for?
What's going on?
Still ready to rock, baby.
I can grab coffee.
Is it worth grabbing coffee to save Flamb?
I don't know what we need.
I think I can get the resting.
Okay, yeah, we can make it.
Alright, nice.
Um...
Is it more so for defense or...
I don't know.
I'm gonna get both just to secure it.
Can you feel both?
it's the fence okay putting golden man punch up yeah i'm gonna do both he fills all do i just trust on golden or should i put both chat we gotta save him we need more people like i mean i hope he doesn't die but also we need more i can't handle with four with three no punch up
oh he does not fill out okay assembly if i was on do not disturb i Anyway, what I miss.
Oh, wait.
He's fine now.
Oh, not much.
Just the end of the fucking world.
All right, we have four now.
Try and put a stop to that.
Get your ass in gear, babe.
We're putting in some mad OT.
Oh, yeah, no, thank God.
Yeah, oh, shit.
Yeah, I swear to God.
I swear to God, it's not fast enough.
Oh, nice.
See?
Yeah, we brought it back.
487s at the mall enough arm looters okay that's fine that's fine that should be everyone oh hey okay we gotta find depression man first signal split can't look for them at the same time gotta pick one to track first depression man how do i pick sorry but i'm sorry look sonar i'm sorry but he is worth more.
I'm sorry.
He is worth a lot more.
Not going for the only guy that can think for you, Andy.
It's a risk I'm willing to take.
Out of range.
Is there like any electricity thing here?
No.
I'm in too deep.
Okay.
I have to make him...
Oh, no.
Wait, what?
Intruder detect...
Oh, shit!
I got so confused!
Okay.
I had to go...
Wait, what?
Oh, top, right?
Stay with me.
Oh, now...
Oh, six, sir!
I got confused.
Now what?
Top left now?
Oh, okay.
Oh, no.
I found it.
Oh, thank God.
Okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
We locked it.
I got so confused.
I was like, what?
What?
it's okay we got him we got Phenomenon okay we don't he's on a train being set wait what before he's in another city wait why is he on a train oh i didn't get the bonus i didn't remember oh wait i did get the bonus i keep thinking this one is nice on the name we need someone to fuse it immediately defuse the bomb who can defuse a bomb Okay,
we got, we got, they got him.
What do you mean by that?
They just, they just got him.
Okay, what was this?
Someone smart?
Um, so nark good.
Fuck.
Fast for this one.
I don't know what I'm talking.
What's that?
these two we really need phenomena man
someone smart um i'm gonna risk it a little bit i can maybe send two and then he'll be just as smart
okay we're using the coffee feeling fresh this is like my okay um five intelligence Okay, we got five.
No, no, wait.
It's okay, guys.
Surely five intelligence is gonna save us, right?
By the powers combined.
We have...
Need a hand?
Oh, my God.
You've got a lot of explaining to do.
Look, I fucked up.
Bad.
Really, really bad.
but can we please all right we got five okay okay this is good all right now we can put me in a cage wait pull him up and rescue him oh okay no we need all this should this should rescue them together you're back in on one condition you fucking survived this area all be piss at you together no promises she looks pretty bleak out there should be fine that's more than enough
We did it.
I knew it.
Okay, guys, I told you.
Our average ITQ combined together will save the world.
It's five.
All hands on deck and our trainees are pissing themselves.
All right.
Join sweet talk and reassuring the trainees that they will not die.
I don't think Depression Man can do either of that, so give me a sec, sweet talker.
I have Flamb.
I guess.
I got this shit.
He can talk a little bit.
I'll wait a little.
I'll wait a little bit.
Maybe I can save him in time.
Oh my god.
Oh, thank god.
We just made it.
Alright.
It's okay.
We got...
Thanks for saving my life.
Let's never speak of this again.
We have sonar coming in.
Very slowly.
Oh god, he's not gonna make it.
Um...
Flamb...
Make way for me.
You know what?
Yeah, you too.
That should be enough to talk to people.
All right.
God, you guys all need to be a little smarter.
Disrupted.
Oh, shit.
Oh, eight.
Eight is a lot.
Oh, Thank God we just made it Oh, thank God Oh, thank God with the power of two With the power of two Here are things all here Some of you in worse shape than others My whole life started to Flash before my eyes I won't lie Wasn't great See, look at that guys,
we saved the city Like, 10% of the people in the city died But, like, 10% is 10% the 90 you live
oh shit water boy give me one second wait am I recruited is he wait is he gonna join my team I mean he has the power of water get in here water boy you're in yeah I am what what spill something use water gun superhero that's not I mean, I don't do why what if somebody spills and mess up I would mess up other people city is on fire You are the most valuable man in Los Angeles.
No, no, I can't my my net worth is Barely hey, hey look water is good against fire
Okay, great Galen okay, yes, sir Can we okay You don't gotta keep saying it, okay, bud.
Can we get the newest Z-teamer Waterboy into the hero pool?
Absolutely.
How you feeling, man?
Okay.
Hell yeah, bro.
You sound okay.
Okay.
Square, did I choose you?
Waterboy.
Not to fear, worry, blazer.
She said you were, it was, um, um, I'm here to help.
man don't hurt yourself glad to have you on the team oh why if it isn't the sdn janitor i'm gonna get so wet fantastic okay okay water boy oh my god okay water okay oh that and your understand golem it's tearing the pier apart wait if i put him here does he spread all the way here
yeah all right oh shit yeah that's right you do the chad is using the chaos to summon their god through human sacrifice oh i sent her oh i got these dickheads and then wait actually let me double check allison expecting explosives we need backup oh shit put out the what what's happening
do you think waterboy can solo this guys it's his side it's okay You soloed.
Yeah.
Okay, let's look at the other...
Get me on my jet right now.
Fuck this shit.
It's...
It's perfect.
Alright, what about you soloed this?
I...
You get soloed this.
I believe in you.
I think you get soloed.
of this gas oh did somebody else for hellfire try to copy air just to be yeah i'll copy her just in case i i believe in water boy branch are all accusing each other of being red ring spies um
what we'll put you two together one four and then you i'll put escort you know what we can't escort each other all right let's see let's see if water boy can solo this
it's fine give me a sec i want to know they can be locked in a little bit longer break off the ring red oh wait let me think about this oh i can't attack you everything break off isn't that both that which one is best guys which one does what break what does attack is break is vigor okay so we have yeah we have higher vigor okay all right we have higher
okay never mind i thought i thought we all right does he solo this
there's no time for this oh okay i don't okay okay guys he he does in fact not solo this guys who would have thought all right remember this left left right up who would have thought i thought he would solo of this.
I don't know.
I thought I would get the thing where you're like, yeah, here you go.
Here's the electricity.
I was so confident.
I don't know why I felt like could be a hero.
I thought it was his time to shine, guys.
Are you fucking...
Oh, yes.
What?
Oh, I can do this now.
He just needs to warm up.
he's just scared oh oh oh this is oh
okay wait
I didn't realize that the wait what
wait what okay guess I'm a little confused how do I get over there
oh there we
Oh, no, this is bad.
Alright.
Oh, this is bad.
JK.
JK, JK, JK.
Oh, JK, JK, JK, JK.
It's making me super nervous, but JK, JK, JK.
Oh, we got it.
We got it.
I got a little nervous there.
I will rescue the students.
They didn't have to die.
Phenomenon!
Okay, I have charisma.
Is that rally them against the real enemy?
Because I assume reason with them is, like, thinking.
Does it rally?
Yeah, that was a little bit too close.
Is rally charisma?
Yeah?
Okay, yeah, we have 10 charisma.
There's no way we can fuck this up.
Oh, thank God.
Thank God.
Okay, we were very much qualified.
I'll say it.
I really feel like I don't get enough credit around here.
Oh, my God.
Please, please.
Oh, thank God.
Okay, we just made it.
We just made it.
We were missing these two.
Okay, that's just tiny.
Alright, nice.
My might is unmatched.
Okay, everything's fine.
LA Country.
Can you experience him?
Oh!
That is more- Oh!
Oh, where are the other heroes?
Wait, all my other villains!
When to- When- when to work?
Whatever it is, it sounds like more shit.
Oh, shit.
What?
Did everyone die there?
The Z-Team!
Get a load of my new friends.
Oh, no way.
That can't be.
Coup?
Yep, with more Red Ring backup.
Wait, who's injured?
I can't tell.
I'm not mad.
I'm just disappointed.
Oh, these two.
I don't care.
Golem.
Fuck, say, Koop.
Why did you have to go and spread those wings of yours?
We want to save this city.
We need to take Koop down.
Without her, the red ring will scramble.
Alright.
Oh, shit.
Locate, coop, interrogate coop.
Cope's crew.
Why do I do that?
I wish to speak with Blonde Blazer about the terms of my employment.
Water.
We are not sending in water, boy.
Punch up and mail?
Holy fuck.
Really?
Punch up and mail?
Why?
Wait, why send in water?
We are not!
We are not sending in water, boy!
We are...
He is not gonna solo, yes, my god, water boy.
Do we need interrogate?
Okay, interrogate.
Yeah, fuck them all.
Oh, we should nobody is.
Oh, wait, and visit girl.
The girl that got her cut.
Let him solo.
Okay.
I think this is good.
what guys look how much water boy increase is this like punch up all right we'll see i'm curious what will happen i'm gonna curious send him send her ass do you shit red ring zooming out tech like it's candy there's a fuck ton of gangs wreaking havoc down here secure the red ring tech oh is this okay there you go oh i should have healed Grotto will never evolve.
A sign is that we're not saying he gains plus one.
Bro, why are you?
Okay, we're going to heal it.
We have to heal water, boy.
Yeah.
There we go.
Okay, there we go.
There you go.
He didn't send himself in.
Thank God.
Okay.
Okay, but he is the second smartest.
If you're not sure, all right.
I'm willing.
Okay.
Fuck it.
I'm there.
That's all about thinking.
okay that's a lot of ground to cover all right here we go oh nice we did it second smartest with three is crazy we've got another gang out here with red ring tech bus secure you know what yeah that's right i want to send i think okay i want to send god damn it red rings put up a road block let's tear it down destroy the to brace yourself for the oncoming for fire with area wait i feel like that needs defense though okay let's check the other one i understand there are higher priorities deliver a large ice matcha green tea light all right we'll send we'll send the water boy for that all right we're gonna put flatbed we'll do these two they haven't been together in a while i'm sick of flying over the same boarding buildings okay i think i can't wait a little bit i'll wait a little bit robert got any z-teamers nearby we got uber east during the uber east during the during during war carried i cannot carry themselves okay that needs mobility everyone's like so far away i can wait a little
bit i think plus the east side
uh maybe these two but i am i need to send three people at once Did anything help?
Toll.
No!
Are you kidding me?
Really?
She always was a hell of a Are you serious?
Okay, that's fun.
That's fun.
That's rigged.
Oh my god.
Okay, we're almost there.
I swear to God if it went that way, I swear to God.
Okay, we gotta have Malik and then my guy's depressed.
Okay.
Okay, this is not going so well for me He just suddenly got depressed.
Um Oh no.
Okay, water boy.
What do I put you with?
What do I even give water boy?
What do I even give him?
intelligent okay he's gonna be my third smartest oh my god we'll go with this first um we'll send you in here this will be your job and then we'll send you oh god oh fuck ignore the coffee the coffee is important okay you're gonna do this You don't understand!
The coffee is so important!
Wait, she's getting closer, guys.
Wait, why?
Wait, why is he waiting?
Wait, oh god, okay.
Oh, the check mark?
Oh.
No, no, you bet!
This is so... Okay, this is fucked.
This is so fucked.
Okay, you better do this.
My money's on Blazer.
That is so fucked!
You're not allowed to bet on yourself.
Yeah, see, we did it.
We got coffee.
Oh, hey.
That's really sweet.
Thanks, man.
What's the bet?
Last one left alive when all this shit goes straight to him.
I swear to God, if it goes down here, I swear to God, if it...
Okay, thank God.
Okay.
We're fine, we're fine, we're fine.
Everything is fine.
Found the distributor of the Red Ring Tech.
It's Mr. Fister.
Befeet Mr. Fister?
There you go.
Can I, am I ready for this?
Yeah, you're so ready.
As long as we stay clear of that one.
Oh, fuck, okay.
I need to be coop.
Oh, my God.
With who?
Okay, I'll send Omni Man.
man in there.
Oh my God.
Nice, though.
Oh, nice.
We just made it.
Okay.
Okay, nice.
Increased chances.
I'm trying to figure out who to send.
We're gonna put...
He's almost less depressed, guys.
I have an idea we'll send him in could be worse and then there we go that's the spirit there we go this will work i'm really gonna enjoy this all right what the fuck what the fuck are you Oh, thank God.
Oh, thank God.
We did it.
The 49% wins again.
Get the fuck back up.
We did it.
Intelligence mobility.
You know what?
We'll make you fast.
Okay, the closest is this way.
Hurry to the tornado.
fast okay you're just gonna be fast for oh wait we do okay you're fine um help we we're trapped inside of the stadium okay we're gonna let these kids are gonna danger but we pay good money for this service what else could possibly be keeping you all right we should save the children i was like we don't need to save the kids and i'm like oh wait i think we should save the children I mean sure I don't think no one knows that we can wait a little bit there's no one in actual immediate danger like yeah it's just a housing crisis what's gonna happen there it's fine oh my god oh thank god sent a lot of people in are you okay okay
Forget the children.
Yeah, I was going to say, does it really matter?
Talk about impatient.
Alright.
Come on.
Nice.
Yeah, baby, we're the motherfucking bridge now.
Trying to brainwash the citizens with her red ring implant.
Smile marks able to convince her enemy to only so much strong metal.
Oh, okay, we got to send him in.
Or I'll send you in.
That's good.
Wait.
Consider my feelings next time.
I feel like I can only send.
No, we can't.
Someone was strong mental fortitude.
Just him.
Yeah, I feel like...
Too much talking is bad.
Yeah, that's why he's just stinking.
Water boy with so not.
Okay, let's see if we have enough time.
No, we don't.
Hey, that red ring creeps smile more.
I can't I can't look at him.
He's still he's EP.
We can't always said water boy Also creepy which is also hot protect the well-being But defenses against your overpowered.
Okay, we got to wait then all right.
Did we do anything?
Oh I forgot he was depressed so he didn't go
What the fuck he was depressed?
Neighborhood watch mobilizing against the red rain.
I thought he'd be okay.
You're not in my city.
Okay.
Yeah, goodbye city.
I think the city's fucked, guys.
I forgot that he was depressed.
Okay.
Are your augments on the fritz?
What the fuck is going on?
I'm trying my best, guys.
But he keeps being depressed.
I don't understand.
Why are you depressed?
Convince them to turn back.
Okay, which one is combat phenomenal aim?
Okay.
just don't be sad send in against coop now oh my god what why i could have killed her if he wasn't
he is helpful but he's just you gotta go solo dolo when they count the most we're just failing slower that's how i feel bro they gotta spread them bro hitting us everywhere can't get a win no kind of way right hey listen up this isn't working this is what they want okay to send us to every corner of the city spreading us then forcing us to travel back and forth no more coming back to base between calls yeah we stay out for as long as we can plan is for us to get more tired than we already are oh shit he knows our procedure so he's predicting our moves so we need to switch it up be less guys i don't think i'm going to win this guys we'll live on and guys guys are cool i We have the damage coop,
boys.
Okay,
okay, okay.
I wish to speak with Blonde Blazer about the terms of my employment.
Oh, oh, oh.
Villains abound.
Oh, God.
Keep them coming.
Oh.
Here?
That doesn't hit it, right?
Does this work?
Anyone but- Yeah, okay.
Okay, go!
Go, go, go!
It'll be the last thing you see.
Please let us off.
Rescue the civilians from canned air.
Destroy all.
Reach civilians before their mob.
Okay, you can't be depressed.
You can't be depressed.
Do not be depressed.
Okay, he made it.
made it guys he made it he's fine he's not depressed guys he made it he made it wait beefcake didn't we fight her last week and has your ability red ring you are get back in here hit beefcake hard and fast okay hard and wait can she heal herself let's rub them up that's fine oh you know what i can do i'll send their friends there you go what's it going to be this time send him and find my heart he can join in
all right this should be a hundred percent all right
okay 86 percent i swear to god if i fail 86 i swear to god i swear oh god okay how much damage oh that is not a lot but that's That's fine.
Send Sonar down here right now.
I've got a knife picked out just for him.
I got this shit.
Spang hot.
Oh, I'm gonna wait a little bit.
I'm gonna wait a little bit.
Yo, we've got a plan, but we need backup.
We could actually turn this around.
Hey, constructed trapage window.
Okay, we're gonna wait a little bit because I need to send people back.
Um...
Okay.
There's serious heat out there.
You're done for.
This should be fun, right?
Mal and Prism?
We out here?
You know this.
Yeah, but she's injured and...
Oh, I have a band-aid.
Thank God.
Okay.
No worries.
What the fuck is going on?
I don't remember what she was best.
Yeah, fuck them up.
I feel like these two, right?
six this should be fine right mel and sonar oh you're right i forgot they have yeah but it doesn't do well because we don't have vigor combat or mobility that has the most reach i feel like which one was it punch up holy shit yeah but like i don't trust him he's gonna get depressed Like,
he's gonna, he's gonna get, he's gonna increase chances.
Okay, I trust you guys.
I swear to God, if they fuck it up again, if they fuck this up, they're never being together anymore.
I don't care about goddamn friendship.
You just don't know when to quit, do you?
Construct a trap who's smart enough.
Let's go, bitches.
All right, you guys have the bonus.
Oh, shit!
First mistake.
go are you fucking kidding me you said hit hard and fast where oh he's out oh yeah fuck is this I've got you oh thank God okay oh thank God thank God thank God okay thank God golems out golems fucking out right now well that's great because I'm in deep ship pretty much constantly my house I was not expecting to see my former lover at a time like this Oh no,
my health!
Oh no!
My health!
Um...
Get hot.
Oh, I don't know.
Would you call a wall of fire?
Oh, I can rest!
I forgot I can rest!
I will revive!
Set fire.
Okay.
Red Ring has attacked the Vincent Thomas Bridge and is now escaping on the USS Iowa.
Need assistance in the pursuit.
Who's fast?
Phenomenal.
Guess what?
This is fat.
Don't be depressed.
It becomes larger.
Yeah.
Are you...
I'm never sending...
I'm never sending those two out.
Oh, thank God.
Oh, oh thank God.
Okay.
Oh my God, everyone's injured.
How can I help?
I'm on standby.
Everyone's hurt.
You do this.
I like being so hands-on again.
I mean, the citywide chaos isn't great, but, you know.
I forgot about- okay, okay.
I forgot about bla- I have blazer.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Oh.
Okay.
Okay, we send blazer into this.
We have to send- Wait, can I even send blazer?
Oh, I can't send blazer into this, because she only wants to see blazer.
Okay, she actually has to heal someone.
Still on my feet.
Okay.
Let them in again.
Okay, I swear to God.
I swear to God, guys, if they fuck it up, I swear to God.
Oh my God.
Bro, her stats are fucking crazy.
Red ring stole one of our news copters.
They're firing out of civilians.
You know what you can go in the copter out now Helicopters are annoying on the best of days.
I'll just send blonde blazer everywhere All right.
Oh, come on
What how did it fail?
When did it trigger it?
What
screen we saw it The synergy guys I told you I Okay.
I was talking.
I told you.
I fucking told you.
I knew it.
Okay.
I just don't have intelligence.
It won't go on the other side, right?
Guys, it's not going to go.
It's because he got healed.
Yeah, but then the defense.
I'm scared about the vigor and the intelligence guys
Oh there's no intelligence okay
But let's predict though Punch bus VC You're done for I mean it's the most equal You predict is intelligent evade is speed and strike is come okay all right we have five this should be fine we have five i'm really gonna enjoy this i can't she healed him and it fucked me over i can't believe it she healed him i'm so sad like she actually healed him and it ruined everything.
I'm putting more intelligence.
Come on.
We so, come on.
We could do this, guys.
50, maybe 60% of the city is dead.
But it's okay.
It's okay.
It's okay, everyone.
We'll be fine.
The red ring has overwhelmed me.
I need immediate assistance.
Okay, you go over here.
Wait.
I have to hit all of that and then i heal sonar again he's damaged right is that damaged and i'll heal you too i'm healing all two of you you have to stop calling me that wait art uh can she heal more than one person or only one person you can only heal one who do we heal will heal his water boy
It's only one.
What is the red thing?
Do I have to hit the red to...
Not to be, like, not on the red?
What is this red thing?
No, if I don't, we don't succeed!
Oh, Waterboykin!
Oh, red is her ability?
I forgot what her ability...
Wait, what was her ability?
Wait.
Where is...
Oh, power.
Oh, the next stab, the next call.
Oh, okay, so I have to be here.
okay no i have to be closer okay
i'll send golem fuck it yeah yeah i'll send golem in so i can i'll heal water boy and then send golem in i'm doing this to heal him i don't care i hate that part of town and all parts of all other towns also use the bomb this is oh my god you got this okay we're said you're diffusing this You're defusing this pop.
I don't think...
I don't think Sonar is going to get it.
Sonar is not defusing anything.
Someone's messing with our systems.
Okay, it's fine.
I want to know this first.
Before I do the hack.
Guys.
We're not...
Guys, no.
I'm not...
Please.
Guys.
You're going to help me for this.
Pretend we can...
Well, I wonder if...
i have anyone in chat that can predict the future okay you're not helping me because you're you're you're all oh yellow red 100 red red red what color is it's random okay red ring oh my god yellow for Doki.
Oh, thank God.
Yellow is intelligence.
Thank God.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
There's no way!
There's...
Invisigal's on her way back to SDN.
Okay, copy that.
We'll make do.
There is actually no way.
let's lock in there's no fucking way there's no there's no way are you fucking kidding me
wait what what uh huh I hate this I that's actually so bullshit
what's going on huh it's a path ah can't follow me here can you hang on something's wrong with my controls oh no oh no i hate this it's inverted doubt i i'm already going through so much man like are you serious I'm so, I'm so over I'm so over this
Oh my god I'm so over it guys I'm actually so over it Like my luck is so fucking bad i'm so sad i'm just i there's just oh my god there's actually no way that happened to me not my you ain't ready for this i don't know like i'm so sad i'm so sad i'm actually so sad how am i that unlucky how am i actually Help!
The deleted!
They're modded.
Oh, no.
Yeah, we're...
I'm on it.
If all else fails, we send in.
You know what?
Fuck it.
Let's just expand though.
They burned down Los Amigos.
And no one else gets the Tostata shell as crispy.
Send you.
You know what?
Why do I go in there?
Don't even try it.
On top of the morning.
Oh, I'm so sad.
I thought our old commute was shit.
I'm so sad.
I'm so fucking sad.
I'm so unlucky.
How am I that unlucky?
Top of the morning to you.
Which uh.
Alright, I mean, there's no way I failed this.
I'm going to take up the entire grid.
Yeah, I covered the entire grid on a single call.
Come on.
Thank God you're not depressed anymore.
This is the longest night shift of my life.
I have to know what this is.
It's made it!
I made it!
I don't think so.
Okay, okay, we've made it in.
me okay it's this the prediction there's okay good we got the prediction in team first okay we got it we have it it's it's winnable
defeat the red ring just go in for i am your doom all right blonde laser you going that's 100 right there okay okay it's it's winnable it's winnable we have hope are you kidding me so hot sonar you gotta dig deep dug all i can man well that sounds like quitter talk didn't know harvard grads were quitters are you serious take that back i will we went.
Oh no, he's not okay.
Oh no, we don't have we don't have second chance.
Oh no, he's out.
Our smartest man is out.
I thought they aren't supposed to be quitters.
Get your shit in gear.
Oh no, we have to send Malin.
Okay.
Okay, we gotta boost you up.
You are the smartest guy left that we have.
You have to be our guy.
There's no way.
I got
15%!
That's happened two times!
I don't think I can salvage this guy.
I don't know if I can...
Oh my god.
Bad!
This is...
Ow!
Okay.
Okay!
This is...
Overall!
That's fine.
Okay.
Scanning by.
I can heal him.
Okay, again.
Again, we go.
Just restart.
I guess LA doesn't want to get saved.
No, no, it'll be fine.
He's not.
Depression man is no longer depressed.
We can stop her.
Serves you right for cutting Cupid the first.
place.
God, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'm, the thing is, we've been doing this for so long.
Nothing.
Like, this is it.
This is the only thing we're waiting on.
There's no way.
Okay, thank God.
Thank God.
I was gonna say, if I fuck up the 90%, there is just pull this off.
Come on.
There's no way.
This is literally it's just me and her.
Give her everything you've got can i say oh god okay no i can't what if he leaves i hope one day i will be can i send blonde blazer can i send her i need a no i need a no if you are sure i'm willing
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, I've like, I've been stuck in this area for so fucking long to a point where they stopped giving me missions.
It's literally just Koop.
I've been stuck on her for so long.
I don't even get missions anymore.
Ben has been drifting around here for 20 years because I'm worried he's gonna get depressed.
I'm not.
Oh my God.
And his name is not Togeeper.
I failed at 80% chance.
Like three times.
Take a deep breath.
Hey, great work team.
The entire city of LA versus one woman.
70% of the citizens of LA has died, but it's okay.
Not good, bro.
I even failed at 95%.
That's crazy.
Chase.
Solid.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Try an exorcism or getting your house cleansed by preschoolers.
Because what the actual fuck you need?
Bro, I've been so unlucky this year.
This year has actually been so bad to me.
He's fine.
Oh.
It seems okay.
All right, take care of him.
What?
Ah, I trusted you, Vizzi.
You were wrong for this.
I'd defend it for you.
Put me down.
I didn't do anything.
No, no, I caught you.
I caught you red-handed.
Let's go of there.
If I was doing that, use your head.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Oh, this before Bros.
Roy, let her go, man.
No, brother.
She ain't going nowhere.
She tries to steal your mech suits.
Oh, fuck off.
And break my heart, brother.
But Vizzy is a traitor.
She played all of us.
That's not what I was doing.
I'm trying to help you.
I trusted you.
Wait, is Roy a bad guy?
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Holy shit.
Is that the real?
She bring the keys to steer the car, but I stop her.
You fucking idiots!
You need me!
You brought the Astropulse.
You already do enough.
You don't know what's coming.
What are you talking about?
Oh, what?
We're here?
I thought she was cool.
Oh, there's cool.
But I beat you up.
Fuck.
We under attack.
Watch her.
Don't get the power back.
You need my help.
You helped enough.
I going.
No.
Wait.
Fire up my super.
suit i don't know what wait i fire up my suit i'm gonna get my suit on what do i call the z team press the oh i choose i'm gonna fire up my suit i need my suit where is my super suit they have jammers up you're not gonna be able to call out or call in that's why this place isn't already swarming with heroes you sure know a lot about the plan for someone not involved Look,
they tried to recruit me.
Of course they did.
But I said no.
Bullshit.
Watch her.
I go get the power back on.
I moved your Mechaman suit to the rec room.
Here.
Take this.
A taser.
We're fighting the red ring, right?
I'm not walking home from fucking yoga.
All I got, brother.
Thank you, dingy.
Keep her tied up.
you can borrow if that's not enough no mr whiskers all
right untie me what why are you looking you didn't lie to me but you didn't tell me the truth she omitted information i'd love to sit here and explain why didn't you tell me a pile of red ring assholes are streaming into the building right now i just don't understand why you wouldn't tell me yeah i was worried shroud would come So if I gave it to you,
he'd have the pulse right now.
I was trying to protect you.
Oh, that's so sweet.
The internal bleeding I've got from your old boss.
Yeah, but at least I didn't die.
You did great, girl.
Thanks for giving me internal bleeding.
At least I didn't die.
Thumbstick.
What?
It's his name because he sticks you with...
Thumbs?
There are fucking idiots, Robert.
I'm dangerous.
I'm fucking around to untie me.
He looks stupid, but he is a killer.
You don't have powers.
You need my help.
I'm tired.
No hesitation.
Two versus one is better.
Two be one.
I'm looking for something to cut you loose, but his toolboxes are locked.
What did he do that for?
Oh, I fucking wonder, Vizzy.
Why would he lock up his tools around invisible criminal thieves?
Robert.
Boy, there's a lot of people coming down now.
great good i've trusted her this far are we in kindergarten guys there's no going back i can't be like there's no backsies i've already stuck my neck out for her we still haven't hooked up yet
i'm fully committed i will get the irl hookup oh it's a quick time event time
What?
Did he not see me?
What the fuck was that?
He needs to use the bathroom.
I hate
this place.
God, come on.
Open it.
Come on.
Alright, alright.
Fuck it.
Okay.
Well, why don't you pee before you come here?
Oh, shit.
While they're peeing, I feel like I should...
I feel like I should get the gun for you.
oh i would i could like it would shock his dick though
oh oh i guess if it was like if i didn't untie her she would have ew if i didn't tie her i had to use that nice job nice job why are his nuts out oh thought that was normal you mind helping him why would you crinkle cut your balls or your zipper if you don't have asking me can you just put his dick away feels like the dignified thing to do oh dignified for who i know the guy a little and it's bad enough he's unconscious all right sure fuck all right piss everywhere yeah thank you that was very decent of you
don't worry i'll do it for her do it for her oh i'm surprised no one shot him yet go get your suit Wait, shouldn't we stick together?
I hate it when she does that.
Why did no one shoot him?
Robert is now gay.
That's all it takes.
You touch one ball, and now you're gay.
It's the gateway drug.
That's the raw.
He had a gateway drug.
Not the only one guy has a gun.
Oh, there it is.
God, these guys are really bad shots.
Like, they have literal enhancers, you know?
Clearly it doesn't enhance the aim.
I did it.
It might have accidentally shot him, but I did it.
Mecha man
Oh, this is the premium package Oh shit, I look like an actual Um Power, like, look at Gundam or Power Ranger Or there's some actual Mecha shit Oh, he's so stretchy This is great Bro, why is he always naked Obviously the suit doesn't work without the Astral Pulse So it is really nice of you to bring it to us your dad would be so proud of you if he wasn't dead because Shroud killed him like he's gonna kill you and all your friends yeah break their fuck you are oh there he is sure oh break all their arms right before we kill them super weird crime scene or just give us the pulse and we'll let you live with broken of course each each one gets broken everyone gets it okay where's shroud you're making it weird where's shroud that is that is that what you're asking yeah yeah that's what i said i don't care about you guys what the fuck am i waiting for okay we're good hey shroud it's like real big but
Oh shit, what the fuck?
Your dad said he'd help me build a Mac If I helped him build the Astral Pulse Just another promise he didn't control on I told you!
I knew it!
How are your stupid spider shit?
I've said it in the beginning!
I knew he made...
I had a feeling he made the Astral Pulse It's like plugging your cell phone into a nuclear reactor.
you're dead i knew it is going to be hard to pull off after i kill you huh oh they don't like that how did he know
energy blades melee time i'll show one for the bullet because it's cooler wait what oh i got confused with the cutscene for the quick time event okay
that quick time event confused me it was so fast you are right brother gun versus sword let's go it is cooler though cluster bomb that's looking right you're
trying yet or is this just a warm-up round
Bro, he's stream sniping me.
He's, like, screen peeking.
Okay, he's a lot bigger.
Still got that new car shine.
Blonde Blazer!
You are late.
My calculations are just showing up 30 seconds ago.
Oh.
Sorry to disappoint.
Oh, never mind.
I can't tell you how boring life is without surprises.
Well, then it's a good thing I can't even predict what these idiots are gonna do.
Wait, the Z-Team?
Oh!
Oh, it's Prism!
Let's go!
Z-Team!
What's the power of friendship?
Oh, yeah, no, he's dead.
Yeah, no, he's fucking dead.
Z team assemble.
Okay, baby.
Okay, I'm more aware now of these quick time events.
Bro, it doesn't even matter.
They just dodge everything.
Oh god, Waterboy.
Oh, man.
Damn, Waterboy.
Oh, shit.
Oh my god, reflection!
With the power of Wainbles!
He touched one ball.
Now it's everywhere.
Do you mean I hit?
How am I too slow?
I hit it!
I actually hit it!
What happens when I don't hit the quick time event?
It can't be slow anymore!
I hope my saving from collision was abrupt.
It was phenomenal
Oh shit Nice nice shot You know I I definitely had that Oh, great.
Well, I'll just go then Bro, no jokes guys.
We're fighting people Guys come by finished our dance mecha man actually I I got the guy for you.
Oh.
Wow.
You really think this little fucking lucky charm is a match for me?
He's got a special move.
What is it?
Oh, ball punch!
Oh, because his dick's out.
No, ending the bloodline today.
Where did you come from?
Oh, shit.
He didn't calculate this.
I see you.
He's a bull.
He should be fine, right?
Robert, this isn't working.
He knows our next move before we- Oh, he keeps stream sniping us.
Oh, no.
Oh, no, it's cool.
Wait, what do we do?
I've never been more insulted in my life.
You fire me, a literal assassin for some moronic bumble.
Yeah, but he has a degree.
Did you know that?
Ask the cleaners how much guano they come across.
Looks like I was right, though.
By the looks of things, I made the right decision.
That's right.
He has a very successful YouTube channel.
What do you have?
Yeah, do you have a degree?
I hit it!
What happens if I don't hit it?
What's the point?
point of me succeeding quick time events if i still get it you're not the boss of me so you don't get to tell me who and who not to murder anymore hey we're your friends please this isn't you help us stop shroud and earn your spot back on the z team
that's where you're wrong i thought i had friends but you made me realize i never actually did I'm just doing what's right for me.
Oh shit.
Z Team.
What a stupid name.
Yeah, you're stupid.
Nah, I'm not fix- I have to fix someone else right now.
I can't fix two people.
I'll try to get you an opening.
Guys, I can't fix everyone.
I bought my limits.
One lady per fix.
There you go.
Five wings.
Is she gonna die?
Oh, oh.
Wait, but I hit it.
Did not hit it?
Come on, come on.
Oh shit!
Yay!
Flying people.
Okay, stay focused.
Sorry, I'm gonna stay focused.
Get him out!
Y'all forever.
Oh,
shit.
Bye, arm.
Calm down.
It was your weak hand.
You can still jerk off.
Maybe if you grip it with the seven button, hold it with.
Yeah, you know what?
Fair enough.
It's not even his real arm.
He's fine.
Let's
attach another arm.
What?
No!
Oh, he wanted...
Oh!
He'll be fine, right?
Oh my god.
I'm trying to find...
I'm locking in so hard.
Oh my god, this scene is so well, man.
is sick as fucked up the animation for the fight oh my god play osu yeah i was like wait this is osu
okay yeah you are
what what chase now what the how long was i out Chase?
Blazer.
What the fuck happened?
Wait, she...
You're not the only one who wasn't born with powers.
Wait, she gave it to Chase?
Holy shit.
Look at you.
Oh, look at you.
Oh, shit.
Yeah, look at me.
Shit.
No, look out.
She's not a muscle bot.
Everything was a lie.
Everything was a fucking lie.
She was never a muscle mommy.
There's always to have a soft spot for helpless losers.
Fuck off.
It's so over.
Oh, shit.
Fascinated.
I guess, I don't know how he didn't.
predict the old.
I guess he didn't think the old man was in the equation.
Fuck.
I'm going to make love to you.
You a hoi.
You're such a hoi.
Bro, you just hugged everyone?
I thought we were special.
Oh my god.
We're not special.
Oh, you didn't know about Blazor's powers.
Oh.
I see.
You didn't realize what Blazer's actual powers come from.
Wait, why did the middle finger get sentry?
I said profanity okay.
Oh, shit.
I looked at chat for one second.
Super Spirit Bomb!
Yeah!
Raise your hands!
We fucked them in the face.
That's what I'm talking about, brother.
That's it?
Let's go again.
Anybody want to go again?
Yeah.
You're alive.
Nice.
I like how...
Yeah.
It changes the hairstyle, too.
Oh, nice ass.
Soccer player is going through something.
Oh.
Beef!
Well,
that is a surprise.
How did he get...
How did he get to feed?
This fat buck.
Like this.
No!
Why is everyone so good?
tense don't worry i'm not gonna drop him because track blonde either i'll just swoop in and catch him anyway what a monster oh i'm killing this oh oh i feel like if i threaten him he's gonna kill the dog i'll be like i'll do whatever you want oh my god i'll do whatever you want because like i feel like if i yeah yeah because like if i say if you drop him i'll you'll threaten him if i threaten him you'll kill the dog threatening him okay sure he dies know this if you hurt him you will die I'm gonna John Wick this and
give me my fucking astral pulse you can still watch you got his dick punched
or a dog don't be shy
sloppy guy is your weakness I knew you'd fall for what is it you call her in physical you knew and she'd steal that soft heart of yours like everything else she's robbed bro that's why we planted her here she thought she had a chance with me she she thought she had a chance she's like what you hooked up with envisagat and not me she works for us too she gets two paychecks for the same job look at her oh she's embarrassed so all that to say there isn't a thing you can do that i haven't modeled out and once i have the pulse i won't need to predict i'll just know so don't around robert not right now what she didn't love me but like did you make her have those sexy dreams about me too monster same time i just want a fair exchange just don't be
I'm a bad person, but I'm a man of my word.
Give me my pulse, and no harm will come to your stupid dog.
You all hear that?
Oh.
I've been through all the game theory on this moment a thousand times.
That's the game theory.
That's the theory.
I'm gonna
give him both.
Because one explodes, right?
So if I give him both, he won't know.
What the fuck is this, Robert?
You said you wanted the Astropulse.
I gave it to you.
One of those is it.
They look fucking identical, Robert.
Look, you're right.
I can't outsmart you.
Yeah, but he doesn't remember which one's fake.
You know what?
I'm not a smart guy.
Yeah, I'll be like, I don't know.
The only way to keep you from knowing what I'm doing is to not have any idea what I'm doing.
Which is how I feel all the time.
But I trust my gut and I take my best guess.
Just like it used to do.
Before you plugged all those fucking Christmas lights into your head.
Before you were afraid to make your own decisions.
Elliot.
Maybe we wait till we get home?
Shut the fuck up!
Yeah, that's right.
You got RNGs.
Oh, that was the right one, wasn't it?
Fuck you.
Oh Why oh He chose wrong
You chose poorly I think I rage baited him didn't I That was Worth the waste there's no way he wins the 50 50
What the fuck?
Feel that, you fucking fucks.
I told you.
I fucking told you, Clouds.
You feel the power?
I see it now.
I can see it all.
How does he... There's no way.
There's no way.
It's not a mutation.
Every...
Is that the prototype?
Fuck!
Wait.
Just a hunch, but I'm starting to think that you guessed wrong.
Yay!
He lost the gotcha!
Let's go!
We did it!
If I can't win the gotcha, no one can!
I just can't beat you.
You know, someone has to clean it up, right?
Let's go back and get the other one.
Don't be mad.
You lost.
Your RG is so bad.
It cursed around you.
Baby, I think it was super chat.
Thank you.
Someone will save us, right?
Oh, what?
She stood in front of the bullet.
What?
Oh, it's her shoulder.
She's fine.
It's fine.
It's a shoulder.
Like, that's just me.
It's fine.
It's the shoulder!
She's okay!
Oh my god!
Holy shit!
I'm Robbie!
I'm Robbie.
Kill him.
Yeah!
Do it.
I'm Robbie
Okay You guys can't be like No hesitation I was saying from the very start I'm gonna kill this man I know backsees
I told you I never said I was I always told you guys I was gonna kill him Since the very beginning when they asked Are you gonna kill him And I'm like yes when I suddenly go, no.
We're not doing Batman rules here.
From Batman, I've learned that you have to kill.
Do it.
It doesn't make it right.
My grandfather and dad are dead.
How am I the one on a stretcher when you look like hammered shit?
Be that as it may.
you did get shot by a gun hospital check is pretty customary after that it didn't hit anything yeah well it went straight through that's what i said quick hero lesson when you jump in front of a bullet you're supposed to actually stop it you know it's kind of the whole point
imagine she actually shot this at someone right now and then or okay i'm blinded someone hey i'm right as i choke someone to death yo thank you super chat thank you thank you this is this is just a precaution look all of this was a real bolster fuck shit show actually i was i was gonna say poop show but i'm trying to sound like less of a dork it's already working I hope the fact that I've always rooted for you makes up forever doubting you.
You wanted to cut her!
You lie!
I don't blame you.
I mean, look how much- Fuck you lie.
I know what you are.
There's always a home for you here, Courtney.
I appreciate that.
I know what you are, you lie.
You wanted to cut her twice.
Ha ha ha ha.
So...
Here we are.
Looks like you did it.
What is the it you're referring to?
A lot, really.
You're not a bitch, apparently.
At least, according to them.
Oh, what do they know?
Very little, yeah, but there's also all that, you know, really heroic shit you did, saving my life and all.
You're a hero!
Does that make you a hero now?
No.
I think it might though Oh, you got something on here.
Oh, he's gonna chase.
He's gonna chase me.
Whoa Water boy.
Oh, now that's not sensei.
Is it still there?
I'm in I did it.
Take care of her.
I did it.
It took me 17 episodes.
I finally is
finally this was the slow the slowest burn of my life holy shit she took a bullet for robert something i would never do it was a targeted attack by shroud and those miserable uh jerks the red ring there's a story out there that shroud was killed by not a superhero but an sdn dispatcher care to comment We did it,
guys.
See, it's possible.
Bitch Shroud deserve what he got.
Shit, can I not cuss?
It's fine.
We can believe it out.
Manny!
Point the camera over.
These are the real heroes right here.
This is the team that thwarted Shroud and the bedroom.
Does your team have a name?
The Z team.
Z team!
These fuckers are the best heroes and the whole motherfucking SD.
Actually, I'm hearing now.
to believe the curse words reporting live from back to the studio we did good our brother man's defend sdns going to do it without you brother brother i couldn't have done it without you seriously all the work you put into the suit is what made this this alien gal to my left it's not the hard part fella all you guys do the hard things well Well,
no, obviously you can do that stuff too.
I saw you were throwing those red-ring fuckers around like graduation caps.
No joke, I started to feel bad for them.
It was mesmerizing.
Yeah, that was a fun scrap for sure.
I'm kissing sleep, bro.
Not a clean-up tomorrow.
Good job, Mecca, man.
Over here!
Oh, is Blind Blazer gonna be, like, a regular girl now?
Oh, God, you're not the wrong girl.
some mix-up easy mistake i mean she looks scary oh they're freeing here did they earn a pardon is that my call you're the one that'll have to work with them forgive wait is forget bad for is i forget it's like i let her go to prison forever right what if i
how much do you want her back chat give us the one I gave you invisible I chose her over my boss what do you mean give her one so demanding chat It's kind of bad though But like good bad or bad We don't negotiate
Patreus is even a super chat Thank you, thank you I did fix I don't want it that bad Sorry good time for brabs Again it's like you know You know someone's about to go to jail But like, you know, a very important person can stop someone from going to jail when they're offered the right thing.
She wasted so much time.
Lock her away and throw away the key.
Yeah, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Do it for Jack.
Did she almost ruin your dispatch?
Next, you think of the super chat.
Thank you.
who's paying her bail who's who wants to pay her bail uh all right i could save her for so that you know our boy jack here can uh you know you know have a win in his life
do it for punch up okay okay we'll forgive all right you're lucky You're so lucky.
Your bail's been paid.
No, they're with us.
Oh, nice.
Forgive your or she'll 3% gift you next to me, which he breaks out.
Here is bail money.
Look, Kroos, this thing you was super chatting.
Thank you.
You're lucky your bail's got paid.
Hey, so you maybe got an extra one of those.
Kill Shroud for his spirits.
hot i wasn't can't control my gun
they see bad hot lady and they're like i can fix it i got it works open beers like normie i was gonna keep her in prison but then you guys paid her bell i've had half a beer and i'm all kupa is just so hot dokey
so is that permanent nah he's borrowing it until we can figure out a different solution for his issue right the whole being on the brink of death issue that's the one well it looks like he'll enjoy while it lasts so do you feel better yeah he got she got pretty privileged after killing shroud yeah robert it feels great
Look, I want to do that again.
I'm surprised to hear that, but...
I suppose I'm happy for you.
Murderer was great, bro.
I should let you know that you're suspended pending an investigation just to formulate.
Toki.
Totally understand.
You did a great job with them, with Invisigal.
She said she's happy for me, guys.
Took a bullet for you and everything.
I wouldn't have put my money on.
this team being the one to save sdn but we're just getting started getting them to not be assholes to each other is the start not the end a lot left to do yeah well take tonight to enjoy it you can worry about what's left to do tomorrow yeah my boss gave me the okay murder is fine gonna have to talk to hr about that we have hr i'm joking oh thank god hr's a joke thank fucking god best joke of the night having hr yeah more than good make her happy because god knows she's miserable jesus but that's my girlfriend i'm fixing here so does this mean the team's off I was just trying to figure that out.
Robert sucks.
I think you might need to go.
I need to take this young man if you don't mind.
By all means.
Robert sucks.
I was wrong about business.
She didn't actually kill me.
Just almost.
Now let's see if I can make you throw up.
Wait, what?
What?
Wait,
how did I somehow end up with a good ending?
I thought you guys said I'm destined for a bad ending.
This is pretty good.
I told you, I'm Robbie.
painful actually i told you guys i'm robin that was the best choice
i barely saved it i told you i do it i was like i fight no matter what robin wins
i saved it
How many endings do they have?
I don't know.
Never punished.
I told you.
Oh, two?
Four?
Wait, what are...
Or two?
Four?
Is it two or four?
All right, what are the four endings?
Was mine the best ending?
Oh, two romance endings, two good or bad.
Thought Squad.
That's a good name.
Been a nice finishing night game with you, Joki.
Story was great, but the dispatch gameplay seems disconnected.
Looking forward to the next game.
Thank you, Super Chat.
Anna, thank you.
Thank you.
On random.
Thank you for the 10 gifted chips.
Thank you.
Sincere romance and kept Invisigal.
Doki was just rage-baiting us with all those losses, guys.
She had it all.
See, I had it all under control.
Guys, I always had it all under control.
So I was like, thank you, super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, so the other ending of God was just like, um, um, Invisigal being a villain, right?
of a whole villain and that would have been the bad ending oh
vc becomes shroud in the bad ending oh she takes over that's right oh yeah i didn't like i didn't want i don't think i would like that ending because that means we wouldn't have hooked up i can't thank you for the super chat thank you thank you yeah i would have liked that ending because we wouldn't have hooked up in the end All right The siege shroud Okay,
we gave him both I'm a kill killer Okay, a lot of us killed him See, it's not that bad We all killed him Well, not all But, like It's not that bad of a percentage Um, crazy Thank you, a super chat Thank you, thank you Six tokens for matching Oh, we're out of gallery And both of them Or just French stone Both of them Then there is a Miz takes the bullet for you Or murder shroud Name of the super chat Thank you,
thank you Wait!
If I go with both of them, will both of them like hook up with both of them like polygamy?
Or would they be mad at each other?
See?
You and 51% players say true to your word and kill Shroud.
I told you I was gonna kill him.
Oh, no?
Ah.
It's complicated.
Only VC.
Okay.
Oh.
This will hate you.
Trust okay 2v1 guys supporting letting her to embrace heroism oh this will be villainy okay we got the sunset don't be green
yay 60% I'll end up made a list if I did but rescue phenomenon first over Sony yeah no I would say that was a mistake yeah Phenomenal depression, man.
Disappointed.
Nailed me there.
He got depressed when I needed him the most.
Right.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
D saves the day.
Yippee.
We welcome.
Oh, so 30% didn't pay the bail.
Unfortunate.
Went on the coffee.
Put away.
Me at 36%.
It's his D.
I performed better than 70% Fuck you Still better than 70% of players After everything How No fucking shot That's fucking right I still did better
There is no way.
Definitely.
Thank you, thank you.
It's funny.
One is to bribe you for coop, but depending on certain things, bomb bays are still censored to jail.
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
That's right.
I lost 380% plus rates and like double.
By the way, there were ones because Sonar had the double spin ability.
So there were times where I've lost two.
280% in a, like, like, twice in one, in one instance, because he has double chance.
That was the worst part.
You barely succeeded a call.
And every man you're a robber always kept everyone guessing what he'll say.
What he'll say, dude, that's me.
For him better than...
Yay!
Look at that.
I prefer him better than 7% of theirs.
ship too you barely succeeded ship was the last episode oh phase two that was phase two i did not feel like the most successful i'm robert i'm robert guys that's insane i can't but i'm so good at this game
wow that was fun i understand the hype now i had oh yeah um one of my friends um who's obsessed with dispatch i think it was like yesterday they were like oh if you look oh do you see anything funny when you because like you know how everyone has their own like um id um so one of my friends was like told me like oh there's an easter egg uh for the the heroes for their id cards And I was like,
oh, what do you mean?
And, like, they, like, sent me a picture of, like, I think, Blonde Blazers ID card.
And they were like, oh, what does, what do you see?
And then I was like, boobies, like, instantly.
Yeah.
So, yeah, so, like, I, no hesitation.
And then my friend was like, how did you know that fast?
And I'm like, because Chad keeps sending me passwords.
Every time I ask for a password, it chat would be like boobs and i'm like it's not boobs and then my chat would be like boobies so i recognize instantly whenever i see the numbers i can instantly tell if you guys fucking type me boobies or boobs like so i can i'm like oh yeah that's boobies like you guys every time i can now instantly spot boobies right away if i It's not gonna work.
What do you mean?
It's not boobs.
One day, it's going to be.
Well, I hope you guys become a successful game developer and sneak that one in for whatever AAA or successful indie game is going to be.
That's your goal.
To make a password where it'll actually be boobies for once or boobs.
good luck dragons good luck i will
anyway guys i'm gonna call here oh my gosh i think oh man i thought like it'd be a short stream because i only had like three episodes but um we i think i think it was because of the coop mission oh my god the coop mission was actually fucking terrible but I'm gonna call it here everyone I hope you had a great time hanging out with me as always um I always have a fun time with everyone here and that you enjoyed my playthrough of dispatch I did enjoy going through this game it was very interesting the story was very interesting um there's a lot of fun choices and everything and you know this I think that the gameplay of being like a dispatcher is such a you know it's a unique concept that I enjoy very much Um,
because, you know, um, we gotta figure out, you know, okay, not the RNG part.
Some of the RNG was so fucked.
I, the RNG was definitely really fucked, but, like, I still had a great time.
Um, Patroesit, thank you, thank you, thank you.
Mark my words, if our next doki fanging ships sometime this century, boobies will be a password to unlock things early.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
I know how CISO feels now in Invincible.
he like hates everyone i understand now hey guys um as always everybody say hydrated posture check get up and move around to get that blood flowing and if you stay up for me head to bed cause you deserve it i'll see you guys next time everybody bye guys bye also cryptic thank you super chat thank you thank you so joki when will we get your dispatch sona and how many fangs will they have let's just be me like let's just be
Look, if I, like, look, if I save 10% of the city, that's a pass for me.
And, you guys, I'll see you guys next.
Oh, yeah, by the way, I can't believe it.
I just realized only 30% of the city survived, but I still pass.
That's crazy.
Like, that's crazy.
Like, 70% of LA is literally gone.
And I'm like, we did it, guys.
We fucking did it.
Anyway, bye, everyone.
Bye.
you